e
good morning if you would please rise
and join me and say in the Pledge of
Allegiance I pledge aliance to the flag
of the United States of America and to
the Republic for which it stands one
nation under God indivisible with
liberty and justice for
all thank you and with that I am opening
the public hearing on House Bill
1713 and invite the sponsor to introduce
the
Bill thank you Mr chairman and members
of the committee for the reckon my name
is Steve schliff and I represent mirac
district 15 which is Ward one of
conquered the village of Penacook and
I'm here this morning Mr chairman to
introduce to this committee house bill
17133 which would allow um would make it
a fense for a person charged with a
class a felony or greater to uh fail to
appear for a trial or any part of the uh
criminal justice
process Mr chairman I retired from the
US Department of
Justice and under rule 42 of the federal
rules of criminal procedure the rule is
that anyone charged with a felony in the
federal court court system must appear
at all aspects of the criminal justice
process uh from the initial appearance
arraignment jury selection trial and if
found guilty be there for sentencing as
well that's for all
felonies what this bill would do would
limit it to a class A or greater felony
um the rule I just mentioned I thought
the state of New Hampshire would have a
similar rule or a similar law to what
the federal government had and it wasn't
until last month that I realized that I
was mistaken about that on December 7th
2019 5-year-old Hony mcgomery was
brutally beaten to death and after an
extensive
investigation her father was charged
with that
murder his trial lasted 12 12 days and
for most of those 12 days of jury trial
Adam mcgomery decided he didn't want to
be
there the jury finally came in with a
verdict they some of the counts they
found him guilty of were a second
deegree murder second degree
assault falsification of
evidence and abuse of a
corpse even when the jury came in with
their verdict again Adam mcgomery
decided not to be
there the judge sent his set the
sentencing date for Adam mcgomery for
May
9th and it's my understanding that uh
Adam mcgomery has already indicated he
did not plan to be there for the
sentencing as
well and the County prosecutor has
already
filed uh a petition with the court
asking that they the court issue an
order mandating that he'd be present for
the
sentencing um as they said earlier what
this bill would do anybody charged with
a class a felony which is a felony as
most of you know with a period of
imprisonment from 7 and a half to 15
years or any crime with a greater period
of
incarceration and that would include
murder fonal sexual assault uh arm
robbery uh kidnapping and several other
offenses
um I
I I'm going to close there but just add
one more thing Mr
chairman when the prosecutor filed his
motion with the trial judge asking for
that order to have Adam Montgomery in
court he said in his Motion in
paraphrase
that how many
Montgomery's family and loved ones will
be in court that day Adam Montgomery
should be there as well to hear from the
court directly what his senters will be
and when I hear that phrase how many
Montgomery's loved ones I feel that that
includes all of us too the citizens of
New Hampshire and I'd be glad to answer
any questions Mr
chairman thank you Mr Speaker questions
for um
represent thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking my question I I very much
appreciate and support the intent of the
bill I I wonder about for example in a
case as you mentioned of fonia sexual
assault for a victim who's
testifying um having to have their
alleged as salent staring at them while
they
testify whether there might be like I'm
just trying to think of the it might be
more uncomfortable to testify with their
alleged as salent staring at them and
I'm just wondering how how to balance
that with the need to make sure the
person is present and I know I'm not
phrasing that well but I hope you
understand no I know exactly what you're
saying um although under article six of
the US Constitution every accused person
has a right to face your
accuser I don't know if a motion be
could be filed with the court by the
prosecutor maybe having them uh testify
by close circuit television from an
adjourning room or to make some
accommodation to make it easier for the
victim especially if the victim is a
minor I think it would be even more
traumatizing to that person but I'm sure
this has come up before in the court I
and again the defense could argue the
article six but I think accommodations
could be
made thank you for that question just to
answer you quick accommodations are made
especially where a defendant is uh
disruptive or threatening staring doing
something to the to the victim the
courts do make accommodations as all the
way from removing them to having them
sit somewhere else um they're very
creative when they need to be further
questions represent
Newman I have just two questions and
they're just mainly about the process so
I understand what the process is and on
uh page one line
nine um it says but upon the motion of
the defendant the court may excuse the
presence of the defendant require by
paragraph one for good cause and I'm
just wondering does the judge make the
decision then does that what they mean
good cause how does that work exactly I
could see a person out on bail uh for um
a class a
felony and having a sickness in the
family having a dying relative or
something really catastro catastrophic
happening in their life where the
defense attorney would want to make a
motion to the trial judge asking that
they allow the defendant to be excused
for whatever just that's why I put in
the words just cause whether it be a
funeral or whatever it might be that
that could be
allowed follow up
and the followup is on page um I guess
it's to the last page um and it says the
term imprisonment pursuant to this
section shall be consecutive to the
sentence of imprisonment for any other
offense so my understanding of that
would be that he would have reached all
of the requirements for the
offense and then if he had not shown up
sometime previously and there was a
consequence to that that consequence
would be cons executive to the to that
previous term of imprisonment and would
follow on after that exactly for examp
for example uh uh someone out on bail
for um a class eight felony a serious
felony in jumps bail and takes off which
has happened before if they do that and
they're found guilty on their underlying
offense
the in would be an additional sentence
on top on and after the original
sentence could I ask one more followup
for it
okay but this in in this section this
section specifically has penalties when
the a person does refuses to to show up
for court even though they're ordered to
and all of that I believe there are
penalties for that because it says
pursuant to this section shall be
conservative and that wouldn't be
jumping bail that would be
he would finish up everything and then
there would be if he didn't hadn't shown
up it would be after that is that is
that right or well what it is is if a
person is uh scheduled to be in court
and would be released on
bail um I know in the federal court is
failure to appear is what the offense is
um if they do not come to their trial uh
actually once the trial begins and a
person should jump bail the trial could
go on an Absentia uh without them being
present because they voluntarily
absented themselves from The Trial
process they would finish with the court
and there'd be a ruling and if they're
found
guilty uh they may
be not captured or not found for years
after when they said after they finished
their original sentence for what they
were charged there'd be the additional
penalty which could be up to the maximum
under article
under um a class a felony thank you but
that again would be discretionary with
the court thank you representative
Balden thanks for taking my question um
is it the case currently that the court
um
can uh or rather that the um
prosecution can request that the court
order the presence of the defendant
um I'm back here so I can look at me
um I look through the um New Hampshire
rules of uh criminal proceedings and I
look through New Hampshire state law and
our house council did as well and
there's really no requirement for a
person to be at their own trial I was
talking to our Mar County Sheriff the
other day and he told me the same thing
often a deputy will go to pick up
somebody in the county jail and the
person will say no I I don't want to go
today okay and that's
it follow
up but um thanks for taking my followup
um but is it currently possible within
the rules in the court system in New
Hampshire for the prosecution to motion
to compel the presence of the defendant
no there's no rule of law that says that
uh a judge can mandate that a person be
in
court I suppose they could issue a
subpoena for them or if it was a
question of
identification um under those
circumstances and I'm sure that'd be a
motion by the prosecution and the judge
could grant that motion and have the
prison but to say I just want to have
him in court without any particular
reason then no but for in the instant
case though in the Montgomery case the
prosecution has filed a motion to compel
him to appear do you know under what
grounds they've they're using to file
that motion no I just know that what I I
read it briefly online some time ago and
I the the prosecutor had just said that
they felt it was in the best interest of
the family and loved ones that they be
in court to hear the impact statements
and everything else and not be excused
so and that's a kind of a good example
to your uh question to uh the fact that
the prosecutor has to file a motion to
get Adam Montgomery in court for his own
sentencing and now it's up to the judge
to make that
determination so just to be clear a
prosecutor can file a motion for
anything but there's no law that would
compel the judge to to actually do it so
I think that's the answer to that um
representative
St thank you and thank you for taking my
question uh I think you've actually
partially answered it that this impact
would uh allow if passed the victim to
face the victim's family the accused and
that the impact statements be read and
they be uh basically held accountable in
public in person versus taking a
cowardly way out by avoiding to go to
their trial when faced with heinous
crimes exactly in in the case we're
talking about with Adam mcgomery if the
judge should deny the prosecutor's
motion to have him compelled to be there
a victim impact statement would be read
but it' be read to an empty chair at the
defense table thank you thank you for
your
question represent
M thank you for taking my
question on uh on line 23 uh of the bill
uh it says a person is guilty of a class
a felony if having been charged or
awaiting sentence for an offense
punishable by life uh life imprisonment
or imprisonment of a maximum term of 15
years or more um the the language in the
bill um uh having been charged or
awaiting
sentencing seems to open the door to the
possibility that someone could actually
be found not guilty of the crime um but
still would be charged with an offense
if they if they didn't appear for some
reason
um uh I guess my question to you is is
does that concern you and is it
something that you think we need to
address in the bill
um it's something you may want to look
at but it actually it doesn't concern me
um it quite simply says that if you're
charged with a class a felony you must
make all Court appearances and that's
why I put the provision in the bill if a
defendants attorney makes a motion to
the court uh saying I'd like to have my
client excused from this court hearing
and these this is the good reason I have
for doing it um then the court would
grant that motion and and everything
would be fine normally if somebody does
not show up at a court hearing they
normally have taken off um there's
always extenda circumstances that
somebody could argue but if it was
simply they did not want to face their
accusers they did not want to have their
day in court then that's a separate
matter but but there is a mechanism to
excuse that person from court if they
wish to absent
themselves but thank you for that
question represent
no thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question um I'm curious and we
might have somebody who's coming to
speak from um the uh judicial Department
I know that it says that they were
consulted um in the writing of this bill
and I'm just wondering if there is the
process of petitioning the court to have
them compelled to appear do you know uh
what what what are the metrics by which
that decision is
made well and this that's a good
question I thank you for it under the
current circumstances with Adam
Montgomery um the prosecutor has taken
has done the only thing that he can do
and that is to petition the judge uh
asking him to compel now the convicted
um person to appear for their
sentencing um that is the only mechanism
available um is to ask the court to
mandate and the judge may very well
order that person to appear in
sentencing but then again they've got to
base it on uh law and um you know and um
president of the court and I don't know
what grounds the judge could give for
saying yeah they need to be there other
than humanitarian reasons I think we all
see
representative
Balden um thanks for taking another
question for me um it seems
like it wasn't helpful in the case
they've been referencing that the
defendant wasn't present that it wasn't
helpful to the defendant's case and I
wonder have you um have any thoughts as
to the pros and cons
of essentially legally permitting
someone to hamstring
themselves versus requiring them to
appear and potentially
losing the impact of their
absence um it's my understanding in this
trial that the judge uh in his charge to
the jury told the jury please take no
inference in the fact that the defendant
has not been present um and again I I
refer to that one part of the bill that
does allow defense attorney to file a
motion with the court and they may not
want their CLI and and I suppose the
defense attorney quit argue in that
motion I feel it would
unduly influence the jury to have my
client present and they Court May grant
that motion but then again it'd be up to
the
court I think we have to be careful not
to confuse the the person's Fifth
Amendment right not to incriminate
themselves in other words not take the
stand versus the mere fact of them being
present in the room um for the for the
purposes of having to face their alleged
victim versus taking an inference from
and not testifying it's it's a different
but close situation further questions I
would just add to that Mr chairman
that's an excellent point uh you know I
spent almost 30 years in the federal
court system and I can't recall any time
an attorney didn't want their client to
be present with them in court and of
course they're not just dressed in their
orange jumpsuits they have them in
civilian clothes uh the jury never sees
them in handcuffs or any other
restraints so U not Prejudice that
shy absolutely
see no further questions uh thank you
for intr thank the committee speaker
anyone else is anyone else wishing to
testifying this Billow has not done so
or signed up to do
so seeing none I hereby close the public
hearing and we are going to take a five
minute
recess so that we can quickly caucus
with our parties and then come back in
and exact this
bill
wish
e
I am opening the executive session on
House Bill
1713 FN and I am recognizing myself to
make a motion and I move ought to pass
may I have a second I'll second
that representative G yes representative
gath is going to Second thank you though
uh secondly by representative Gite I
will speak to my
motion um as we've all aware of the the
the case that spurred this
bill um it it's horrific and for that
family to not be able to face the person
who did this is I think a
revictimization of them twice over
having said that we don't legislate
based on one
case but what one case can do is
illuminate for us an existing problem
and the fact that we have I would say
conflicting laws on one hand we passed a
law that says victims can have a victim
Witness impact statement where they can
tell the court the damage the
perpetrator did to them and also many
times the letter is to the perpetrator
saying this is what you did to me and my
family and I hope you don't forget
that at the same time letting the
defendant basically say I don't care and
not show up really makes the first one
worthless what good is telling uh or
writing an impact statement to to a
perpetrator if he doesn't have to hear
it so based on that I think that it is
imperative that we make sure that people
that commit these crimes face up to what
they have done and not only for
themselves and the victims but for the
public at large to see that Justice
there's a there's a penalty for for
breaking the law and you will have to
face it also I would point out that
there are safety valves built into this
legislation where a judge will have
discretion in certain circumstances to
say this person doesn't have to be here
for various
reasons the prosecutor can even use that
to say we don't want this person here
for various reasons be intimidation of
witnesses or the jury or what have you
so there are mechanisms in this
law as I said that are safety
vals so I would urge you to support this
and vote ought to pass representative
here gather would you like to speak to
your second yes um I truly believe this
is a good bill and and um but I did have
somewhat of a concern um that a person
would be punished
um even though they weren't found guilty
yet so I think for me I like the idea
more so that the person has to be there
for sentencing but I'm going to vote for
this
bill um because I believe that it's at
least trending in the
correct way for um someone that refuses
to show up in their court
appearance thank you further discussion
representative
seig thank you um uh like representative
har GTH I to like the intent of the bill
I understand it it makes sense to me but
I have concerns also that it has to be a
a consecutive sentencing and that it
doesn't give the judge leeway or
flexibility I feel like our judicial
system is designed to allow our judges
to use their best discretion in
sentencing and and that's an aspect that
concerns me so I'll be voting in support
of the bill but I am hoping that there
will be a essentially a floor amendment
to address that and perhaps also maybe
make it that they have to be there for
victim statements and sentencing but not
necessarily mandated for the rest of it
if that's truly their
choice thank you um representative Stone
thank you Mr chairman and I think this
bill is a necessary tool that the judges
can employ if it passes into law in
addition I think we have a history in
this country of having public trials for
a reason and that includes having the
defendant and victims both at the trial
to be heard in public uh we don't really
have closed criminal proceedings
therefore I think it's more appropriate
to have a defendant at a trial
especially to hear the impact on the
victim's family or from the victims
themselves I think a lot of times in
this committee we seem to focus more on
the defendants and not enough on the
victims in the impact that they have or
their families if they are no longer to
have the ability to hear it for
themselves thank you I just wanted to
add something um in in response to what
representative said
uh made she made a good point with
regard to discretion for the judge and I
would point out that this Still Remains
um there there's not a a a minimum
mandatory sentence applied to this um so
if a judge were or a jury were to find
someone guilty of this secondary offense
they could sentence them to one day on
and after um they could stay um a a
sentence they could suspend a sentence
there there's no minimum mandatory it
just says consecutive so whatever they
get
has to be after this but it doesn't say
they have to sentence them to a certain
amount of time or a certain punishment
so they still have a lot of discretion
um representative new thank you Mr chair
um I will be voting in in support of
this bill um and I just wanted to you
know I I've uh been an activist and an
advocate for quite a while and one thing
that that we say is that stories are um
the most important thing you share your
story it connects with people on a human
level
um so the most important thing for me
about this bill is for people to be able
to um to connect beyond what the
criminal justice system and Punishment
can do but be able to connect with um
with the perpetrator and uh and
hopefully get to a point of um healing
and hopefully uh make a a a really true
impression um with the person who's
committed these crimes and and I that's
my hope thank you thank you in in
response to that I would say how many
times have we seen to the shock of us
all where the victim has said to the
defendant's face I forgive you and that
is part of their healing process to be
able to even say that and that could be
taken away by someone not showing up as
well representative sik again thank you
Mr chair and uh for pardon the
interruption um I just we have a
delegation who's come in from Macedonia
um to observe us for a little a little
while and I just wanted to welcome them
to our executive session to watch our
proceedings and how we are able in a
bipartisan way to discuss issues thank
you and and welcome to the New Hampshire
house and to the criminal justice
committee I'm not sure if you speak
Greek or whatever what language
Macedonian is but I only know English
and German so you're going to get
English
today
um uh representative
Muse I I do wish that uh we would have
had the opportunity to hear uh
um other folks with more knowledge of
our of our legal system weigh in as we
usually do on bills like this and I
understand that we're under a a very
very tight time frame um I intend to
support the bill uh I also intend to go
out and ask some of those folks uh what
they think about this bill um if they
think there are things that we may want
to adjust uh and if we do find things
like that um we will uh address them in
a floor Amendment
thank you thank you representative
Newman thank you Mr
chair um I disagree with the that there
is not a mandatory minimum here and the
reason I say that is that if you look at
line
23 it says a person is guilty of a class
a felony if have having been charged or
awaiting a sentence of for an offense
punishable by life imprisonment or
imprisonment of a maximum term 15 years
or more the p and the person person
knowingly fails to appear or refuses to
comply with the transport order that
they are guilty of um let's see where I
can find
that they're guilty of a class a felony
and then if you go to what I brought up
earlier which is p line three on the
next page that says the term of
imprisonment imposed by pursuant to this
section and the term of imprisonment is
whatever I just described it shall be
consecutive it doesn't say it can be
reduced it doesn't say anything like
that so you can you have you could end
up with two consecutive 15-year
sentences and the second one in my
opinion is a defao mandatory sentence so
I that is a big problem for me with this
bill I think that language should be
changed but I am going to support the
bill and um just put that out there so
that it can be dealt with
wherever and I I appreciate you um being
willing to do that and I would encourage
you to talk to um someone from the court
or an attorney um because I'm fairly
confident that it's not a minimum
mandatory the the consecutive is
mandatory but what you get sentenced is
not mandatory because you are found
guilty of a class a felony the judge
still has discretion as to what he
sentences you to for that class a felony
there is a sentence um up to you can be
sentenced to but whatever he sentences
you to he could suspend it he could do
all kinds of things but if you are
sentenced to incarceration it would be
on and after that portion is mandatory
but the amount is not um but we can work
that out and I appreciate your support
of the bill this morning further
discussion seeing none I'm going to ask
the clerk to call the role at this point
the motion on the floor is ought to pass
Vice chair roads yes representative
Pratt yes representative scitec
representative
PR representative
janen
representative
Reed yes representative Stone yes
representative tenar yes representative
har G yes representative Muse yes
representative Brennan yes
representative
Murphy representative Newman yes the
clerk votes yes representative Newell
yes representative suig yes
representative wheeler yay chairman Roy
chair votes yes 15 Z by a vote of 15 to
zero the motion of all to pass carries
um I understand there's going to be some
discussion regarding possible floor
amendments at this time I would like to
put it on the consent calendar if we
need to pull it off to do something with
it then we can do that um is there an
objection to consent at this point yes I
object okay so it's not going to go on
consent with that I close the executive
session okay I'll start with
public I'll do the I'll do the
report
e
on
that I'm opening the public hearing on
Senate Bill
482 and invite the prime sponsor to
introduce the
bill
good morning Mr chairman and good
morning honorable members of the House
criminal justice committee for the
record my name is Sharon Carson I have
the pleasure of representing Senate
District 14 comprising the towns of
londonairy Hudson and Auburn and I have
for your consideration this morning
Senate Bill
482 um it try it seeks to give the N na
New Hampshire Air National Guard Army
National Guard and the 157th air
refueling Wing offices of the Staff
Judge Advocate access to criminal
records criminal investigation records
and court records of New Hampshire
National Guard employees and service
members for The Limited purpose of
carrying out the offices uh
responsibility this proposed legislation
provides statutory authority to the New
Hampshire National Guard attorneys to
access the confidential criminal records
history records criminal investigation
documentation and public uh court
records of current National Guard
Personnel this proposed legislation
would provide these attorneys with the
same access that local County and state
prosecutors have there is currently no
New Hampshire statute that provides the
New Hampshire National Guard military
attorneys with the authority to obtain
confidential criminal history records or
criminal investigation
documentation as such they have obtained
drastically different responses to
record requests to State and local law
enforcement agencies the range of
respons has varied widely from a full
release of an investigative case File to
denial because the law enforcement
agency treats the request as a right to
no request under the latter no New
Hampshire Inter National Guard attorney
has been previously advised that no
information would be released unless
unless
authorized uh is authorization is
obtained by both the alleged offender
and the
victim the proposed legislation would
enable the New Hampshire National Guard
to take appropriate security measures
and when appropriate take necessary
administrative actions against soldiers
and employees based upon the information
collected through Criminal
investigations this is something that is
quite frankly very very important many
of the National Guard members as well as
the civilian employees have security
clearances and they hand they they
handle um High CL highly classified
documents and if a National Guard member
or employee has come into contact with
any kind of Civilian legal authorities
that could affect their security
clearance and whether or not it would
get revoked or amended um but right now
they don't have the ability because they
can't uniformly get those
records because the potential actions
that may be taken are not judicial in
nature the due process rights within the
New Hampshire criminal justice system of
the National Guard employees and service
members would not be affected by this
legislation um I'm not sure if any you
know but I teach um at the N Community
College in nashwa and when I teach a
section on our Judicial
System often say we have three Judicial
Systems we have the federal we have the
state and then we have one that we
voluntarily submit ourselves to and that
is the military um it's very very
different than a civilian um system of
justice and many people don't realize
that um um the proposed legislation um
does not provide access to the police
records um of a New Hampshire citizen
who is not a New Hampshire National
Guard employee or service member um at
this point Mr chairman um I will
conclude my testimony the uh the
Commanding General of the National Guard
is here and he's uh can answer any of
your questions um so I would again thank
you all for your time this morning I
appreciate that thank you very much
thank you Senator um we will reserve the
questions for the thing thank you for
your time and bringing this spill for
consideration uh the chair calls um
General
melittis good morning Mr chair committee
members for the record a Major General
David meletus the agent general for the
New Hampshire National Guard with me
here today is Captain Ryan Alis a
military attorney a former County
prosecutor so it's just simple um we are
a standards based organization this is
about good order and discipline if
inappropriate uh if if inappropriate
actions occur in the outside in the
private private sector we don't have
positive authority to coordinate with
civilian law enforcement agencies to
find out what our service members may
may have
done um based upon the Privacy Act and
some other and so no law enforcement
agency is the same within the state they
have different jurisdictions so the
challenge we have is if inappropriate
uh we may or may not find about it or we
don't have access to those records so
the senator alluded to the fact that
security clearances that's one same
thing as domestic violence if a service
member's commiss domestic violence um is
convicted of it um that infects their
employment they can't carry a firearm
they are non- Deployable and we kick
them out of the service so having access
to criminal records allows us to instill
is a standards based organization good
order and discipline no more no less and
subject to your questions like I said I
have a military attorney here who can
ask you uh answer any questions you may
have thank you thank you General um my
first question would be does does the
CID currently not have access to if they
open a criminal investigation on the
military side to the civilian
records uh this is Captain Alis uh c
will conduct investigations for active
duty soldiers uh who are under title 10
but most National Guard soldiers are
under title 32 status and when they're
on state active duty they're under Title
5 status uh so CID will not investigate
and therefore we don't have access to
C's um access to military records okay I
see so the National Guard doesn't have
the same uh an agency equivalent to the
CID to be able to carry out those
criminal investigations without being
able to get these records correct yes
sir thank you Captain um further
questions um representative n thank you
Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question um I think you know it's it
sounds like a a good bill my question is
um do you think that this is limited
enough in scope to people within the
National Guard Etc who would need to
have this information for the purpose of
of carrying out this or it doesn't leave
it open to um being open to anyone in
the in the National
Guard so the the bill only provides
access to military attorneys judge
Advocates uh so uh it is limited to
attorneys who would be advising commands
as to how to uh enforce good order and
discipline it doesn't provide access to
uh commanders uh ncos or anyone else to
request and get uh criminal histories or
criminal reports and ma'am to give a
context you have about 3,000 Uniform
service members we probably have about
15 18 milli attorneys okay thank
you uh captain could you please just for
the benefit of the committee if you
could and I know this is a big ask in
like a minute explain how the Judge
Advocate General Corp is both the
prosecutor and a defense um because it
can get confusing in other words in your
prosecutorial role you might pull these
records and the guy who prosecuted
yesterday might be assigned to defend
that same Soldier the next day could you
explain that for us a little bit uh that
used to be the case sir however uh
that's no longer the case uh judge
Advocates are either assigned to a
commander uh and such as myself I'm a
brigade Judge Advocate and I have
another Captain who is a military
Justice adviser we ADI advise a 06
Colonel on Military Justice and all
operations however in within our state
in the New Hampshire Army National Guard
we have a O2 first lieutenant Lieutenant
Aria who is a trial defense service his
Judge Advocate his sole role is to
defend soldiers within the state of New
Hampshire and his chain of command Falls
outside of the State of New Hampshire so
his rating chain goes to a uh person in
Massachusetts to another person in
Pennsylvania up to someone at NGB I
previously held that role uh for a
number of years uh and it ensures that
soldiers are not uh uh under the
influence of command within the state
and can do the uh best job to zealously
advocate for that Soldier the Air Force
has the same type of thing I believe
it's called area defense Council well
I'm glad to see things have changed for
the better in 30 years um any further
questions regarding this representa Muse
thanks for taking my question my
assumption is there would need to be
some violation of military Justice in
order to precipitate this type of
Records request or does it work the
other way would you actually want do you
I guess do you envision this uh also
working perhaps as a notification system
that would that would uh uh essentially
allow you to be notified um if if a
soldier was found guilty of something
like a domestic violence charge I'm I'm
a little curious just exactly how you
envision the statute
working sir I don't think the statute is
written to be a notification system I
don't think that it creates any burden
on law enforcement to actually inform
the New Hampshire National Guard that
there uh has been a conviction or any uh
interaction with uh law enforcement
however it does enable us to get police
reports uh the intent is for us to upon
finding out that a soldier has been
involved with law enforcement to reach
out to law enforcement and get the
police reports uh and take action in
that regard uh generally when uh
soldiers have been involved uh with law
enforcement it creates either a security
issue uh that we need to review or
creates as you said uh a potential
violation of the uniform code of
military
Justice um
followup
so the way that I I read the statute and
and please excuse me I'm I'm just I've
read it about two or three times but the
way that I've read it
um is that uh it not only would allow
you to request records for an individual
Soldier but it almost looks like the way
it's written you could actually request
the records of all your
soldiers um is that part of the
intention behind this no it's not sir
it's it's the first one right it's it's
a function of um uh if there's a
domestic violence issue right um
generally speaking on minor mem meters
solders self-report they'll tell their
chain to come in I got get a speeding
ticket or I DUI and then but sometimes
when there's inappropriate behavior we
may not be notified so then for us it's
you're trying to search for the
information to ensure that Hey listen
did that really happen and that's when
sometimes our privacy act like the
civilian law enforcement may not share
with you so it's the same thing domestic
violence sexual assault it's we just
trying to get aware of that specific
issue for that specific Soldier and like
Captain ol alluded to is they're
assigned a milit attorney Judge Advocate
in their defense um when we take the
disciplinary
action thank
you with regard to security
clearances not knowing about a soldier's
um potential civilian um problems could
that make them open to possible
blackmail because someone could threaten
to out them to their command if they
didn't re certain information or things
like that could you touch on why it's
important that there's full transparency
for someone who holds the
clearance that's probably you
sir no no so uh I would say this um you
know we have several positions or job
categories that require different
security clearances right there's a
standard secret clearance there's top
secret and there's other sort of caveats
associated with that right so for
example all our military police um and
security forces both in New Hampshire
Army and a National Guard require
security clearance so you are correct
that if inappropriate behavior occurs
and we do not know about it to revoke
that security clearance is actually
somewhat of a big deal and there was an
unfortunate issue in Massachusetts
recently uh that sort of brought to
light um some of the issues with
security clearance and who has access to
what type of material so yes it is a big
deal thank you I guess what I was trying
to point out is if someone held a highly
classified security clearance and had
certain information
and the command wasn't aware of what
they were involved in in the civilian
law enforcement someone seeking to get
information from them could say unless
you want your command to find out about
this you better do what we say it makes
them susceptible to to um to losing
their clearance because of that any
further questions I think everyone
understands how important this is um
seeing none thank you oh did somebody
else did you have one oh okay thank you
um General and Captain for coming today
and I think we have a pretty good grasp
for us thank you very much thank you sir
thank
you uh chair calls Kevin
Grady thank you Mr chairman ladies and
gentlemen of the committee for the
record my name is Kevin Grady I'm a 25y
year Air Force veteran and I'm a 25y
year resident of the town of hookit New
Hampshire today I'm here representing
the 20 member organizations of the state
veterans ADV advisory committee and we
are uh chared by state law 115 colon
a-8 to speak for the veteran Community
uh in New Hampshire and one of the
things we do is we look at bills that
have veteran impact we take a position
on them then I come and tell you what
that position is we do wholeheartedly
support this bill we think that that
where possible uh civilian law
enforcement and military law enforcement
should work hand inand to the best that
they can and and I want to share a story
that that from my career on active duty
that might put some of this a little bit
into perspective for you uh in the mid
90s I was a flying squadron commander
down in Panama City Florida and one day
I get this phone call from this man who
says I'm with the National Security
Agency and I think that you should
revoke Sergeant so and so security
clearance for that possession of
marijuana conviction he had three months
ago up in Alabama and I went excuse me
what uh so I had no clue whatsoever that
that any of this had happened um as far
as security clearance items go this man
had a security clearance because most
people in the Air Force do have a
security clearance but but he held held
a job that uh he was packing my
parachute he was in my life support shop
I'm not sure I want that person you know
and then when I got into the background
on the arrest thing they there was a
traffic pullover they were literally
smoking it in the car while they were
driving and and so that's bad uh so have
this knowledge is is where we can work
together is is a good thing and I've
also seen it in my career where you know
the the the local the in the
relationship is so good that the
military and the civilian uh folks get
together and say do you want to talk do
you want to do this or do you want us to
do it and then they they sort of pass it
off and say yeah we'll let we'll go
ahead and let you do it and just because
somebody has tried in the civilian world
for a a crime doesn't mean that
non-judicial I can't do things like give
them letters of reprimand or take
Stripes away from them or take pay away
from them those kinds of things on a
non-judicial basis that's really all I
wanted to tell you we do support this
bill and we we hope that you'll you'll
move it
along thank you any
questions just to touch on that it's I
think that if anyone ever watches like
NCIS um do not believe that that's not
how that works military uh police are
not out there um investigating crimes in
the civili world um no they're not no
further questions thank you for your
testimony thank thank you
sir uh the chair calls um Victor Muzzy
from the New Hampshire State
Police Captain Victor muzy I always
forget your rank thank you Mr chairman
members of the committee I just wanted
to speak very briefly after speaking to
the good Captain here behind me about
the intent of the bill uh originally our
fiscal note I think kind of addressed
the costs associated with uh our state
criminal conviction record and also um
the FBI record and as I understand it
it's really not about necessarily the
criminal record it's more about police
reports if you will and court records or
documents and things like that and from
the from the law en enforcement aspect I
can understand some of the apprehension
that maybe some departments have had
relative to releasing these records um
like if it's not an arrest report or an
arrest record but rather an
investigation report there might be some
apprehension there given um the
defendant's position you know are we
going to get sued if we release this
report who we releasing it to you know
for what purpose what does it get used
for so I think this bill will clarify
that and allow uh some protections I
think to the agencies where these
gentlemen may be looking for reports
legitimately so and it's this is really
a matter of public safety um and um
public service and and it certainly
makes sense to me that these things be
available consistently for these these
folks to do their jobs for the reasons
stated and so I just kind of wanted to
correct I guess the fiscal note from
from our perspective as the good Captain
tells me it's it's not about paying the
$25 to the Department of Safety um it
it's more or less just having consistent
access to these things and so um for
those reasons you know I think I think
we would support the bill or the idea
behind it and make sense that um there's
equal access to these things for this
limited purpose uh and I appreciate the
questions about whether this would open
up other people to getting a hold of it
and I like the idea that no it it's
specifically for these judge advocates
in that process and um I think that's
all I have so I'm I'm happy to take any
questions to the best of your knowledge
there's nothing in this bill that
exempts them from the unlawful
distribution of criminal offender record
information is there they would still be
held to the same standards as a New
Hampshire law enforcement officer would
correct that that's my understanding of
me yeah it just allows them what I would
consider consistent access in the brief
conversation we had it sounds like one
agency may be full willing to give them
everything another agency makes them
jump through a bunch of Hoops to get
what I would call or consider basic sort
of Records to have an understanding of
what occurred so I think it I think the
same standard would apply relative to
the the federal record and the state
record and the Privacy um inherent
privacy protections that are that are
there for
those um one more question and I'm not
sure if it should go to you or the other
Captain do you currently have uh the
ability to access Federal triple I
records or do you not have that ability
without going through a a New Hampshire
law
enforcement we tried to briefly discuss
that and I'm not I'm not sure so we
don't know what the what the the answer
is
but uh to be frank sir I I don't know uh
if we had any difficulty going uh in
getting those records through uh New
Hampshire uh law enforcement we would
contact federal law enforcement and
we've never had any problem getting any
records through federal law enforcement
I just wanted to make sure that this
encompassed enough because of the fact
that we are surrounded by several states
where your soldiers could go and get in
trouble if you couldn't get that record
from a New Hampshire law enforcement and
Maine said no or Vermont said no you'll
be back to square one again so I want to
make sure that our people are covered so
okay if if you can get it from the FBI
that's fine yeah that's what I was going
to say chairman I just think you know
from our perspective if they have
another another Avenue to get it that
doesn't involve safety y um if if the
expectation were that we were going to
disseminate it that would be probably
another conversation and maybe some
cleanup language if you will and either
this you know RSA or another one just to
ensure that that we were authorized to
do that for that purpose I mean in my
mind the these these gentlemen are law
enforcement as much as I am or public
servants as much as I am and so I just
would want to clarify um if if there
were an alternate path that that was an
okay practice you know but it sounds
like they have alternate means to be
able to obtain that so that's good good
excellent all right see you no further
questions uh thank you for your
testimony Captain is there anyone else
wishing to testify a spill who's not
already done so seeing none I hereby
close public
hearing
what's
next
e
I'm opening the public hearing on Senate
Bill
376 and invite the senator to introduce
the bill uh good morning Mr chairman
members of the of the committee I'm
Senator David Waters District 4 here to
introduce Senate Bill 376 uh
establishing a Corrections education and
Vocational uh Planning Group um I will
just briefly say about the uh bill
before we turn to at a moment that
you'll see that establish uh correction
education vational Planning Group
certain folks on it and um then a set of
Duties which I will discuss a little
more detail later but I'd like to
provide first a little context about um
why this bill came forward and why this
is going to be a very useful tool for
Department of Corrections to move
forward on education programs um I have
a handout that is uh going around um
this uh Bill arises out of the fact that
the um Federal legislation has
reestablished the uh pel program for
incarcerated people it's a second chance
pel program um pel education grants for
incarcerated folks was uh eliminated
back in the 90s in the in the crime Bill
and uh there's been a desire really
arising from the prisons themselves and
others to say this is one of the best
tools we have to help recidivism
Workforce Development and uh atmosphere
within the in the prison is to be able
to have these educational programs um
available and the funding for them then
can come through the second chance pel
uh program so uh a year or so ago the
New England Board of higher education uh
on which which New Hampshire is a member
of is the six New England states which
deal with all kinds of educational
policy they got a planning Grant set to
commission to look at how we're going to
respond what what should the states do
what sort of Departments of Correction
do what should our uh University and
Community College uh system do um to be
ready for Second Chance uh P funding and
so you have before you a few pages of
that um report a little description of
what nebby itself uh does and I will
mention that um we have representation
on the executive committee of new Eng
Board of higher education from our uh
University system Chancellor or
Chancellor of our community college
system um legislative representative
that's myself and then a legislative
advisory uh committee um of New England
Board of higher education which has
several legislators um from both both
bodies or members of of
that um there was a larger funding uh
received for that effort uh from
ascendium group and uh I just just now
has been announced that ascendium has
provided $6.7 million to the New England
Board of Ed higher education to provide
uh grant funding to the states so we'll
have a good opportunity to get some
funding to help um setup programs that
we're going to we're going to set up um
you'll see in the third page of the uh
handout um you know which I'm sure you
all on this committee are familiar with
the benefits of this uh education and
prison programs help with facility
safety they help with Public Safety in
terms of people
returning um self-efficacy people you
know take charge of their own lives uh
through educational programs and then
are ready to go out into the into the
into the workforce and reintegrate into
the into the communities as they
continue um their
education what the commission
recommended was to look at uh
prison-based issues you know what do we
do to ramp up these programs what are
facilities Technical and uh other kinds
of needs that might be uh on that and uh
then what kind of Partnerships the
community college system uh we already
have once the pel grants uh became
eligibility became clear there were um
an early desire from the community
college system and Department of
Corrections to set up a partnership with
white M White Mountain Community College
uh to start ramping up educ Educational
Services and we'll hear more about this
um but also then communitybased uh what
do we need to do to have support
services and make it seamless so trits
credits can transfer and that people
when they emerge from their educational
programs uh in prison if they want to
continue their education they haven't
completed a degree program we'll be able
to have the community wrap around the
easy entry into our community colleges
and uh University system um there are a
lot of recommendations that came out of
the commission that's what commissions
do as you know uh I wanted to focus in
this bill on the um state level
recommendations which you will see
listed on the next page of your um
handout and so what this bill does is it
provides us really with the
liaison uh it through this body that
will the bill will set up so that we can
work uh with these Partners um in state
and out of state to do what we need to
do for our department of corrections um
other states around the region are uh
taking similar approaches to this or
somewhat different approaches that you
know each state is different and the
Department of Corrections uh is
different as well so to just to return
to the bill um you'll see who is uh on
it I I do really want to commend the
leadership of uh commissioner Hanks and
we have Nick Nick Duffy here from
Department of Corrections uh who have
been really instrumental not only in the
commission when it was uh meeting last
year but also in shaping this bill so
that it could work for the Department of
Corrections um and then also want to
particularly um thank both the uh
University system and particularly the
community college system because they're
you know they're the first ones who will
be stepping up to help um provide these
programs um you'll see uh other uh
people who you know will be connected to
the goals of the overall program
rehabilitative Services Department of
Corrections uh Employment Security so we
can have kind of have a sense of how is
this educ education the kinds of
programs people are going to take and
actually connect to jobs that they can
get um and I will note that a lot of
businesses now are actually looking at
apprenticeship programs and work
opportunities for incarcerated folks um
and so it' be a good opportunity to uh I
I thought to make sure we're having the
education connect to actual skills uh
and
employability um and that's why we also
have the Department of Business and
economic Affairs um of course Department
division of adult
education we will certainly be looking
at those uh incarcerated folks who may
need um some adult education services to
make sure they're ready to take college
level uh uh courses um and then um
design from the Newland Board of higher
education because of all the money that
potentially be flowing to us from the
board of higher education uh to help
fund through grants some of our
activities um that's I thought that
would be a good person to have on here
and um get some advice somebody who was
formally incarcerated and did education
in prison as well so we can know kind of
what works for for the people that we're
um hoping to focus on in in this um so
you'll see the duties here uh and you
know as you're familiar with in these
kinds of uh of bodies um the kinds of
things they need to do starting the
bottom of page one of the the bill what
kind of Partnerships do we need so we
make sure that uh credits work and
programs work uh treit credit impacts
you know that's something that's
important now throughout the system you
know we're trying to create the seamless
flow from high school to community
colleges to University and we want to
make sure that um whatever programming
and educational program people take in
while incarcerated that they have a a
seamless credit transfer when they want
to continue their education any college
readiness programs that we uh we might
need through adult education um are
there ways in which we don't have to
reinvent the wheel if there's a good
program or course being offered at
another New England College University
um through the New England Board of
higher education one of of our huge
benefits out of that is that we get New
Hampshire students of any kind get to
take um courses at the other
institutions throughout New England if
they're offered without having to pay um
so that that might be a way to uh save
us some money and the cost of setting up
programs if there's already one existing
that people can participate um look at
the labor market needs
um as you know we're looking to build a
new uh Men's prison um we have a pretty
good facility for the women now and so
in that process uh ongoing discussions
about how they going to be facility
needs now and in the future for
educational um
programming uh and um career
Pathways um how the pel grant funding
might be
supplemented when individuals
leave uh incarceration and I've had some
conversations with the um university
system and they have their granted
promise where they agree to top off the
costs beyond what pel grants provide and
that would apply to this population as
as well um take a look at are there
going to be any budget needs and we're
can we get some funding I mentioned
we'll get money money through the
ascendium grants you've got a in your
handout a couple of this has just been
announced but a couple of preliminary
things of how the money is going to flow
over the next few years and the kinds of
buckets that it's going to go into and
you can see
the opportunities that we will have
there for uh for this and we'll get some
reports so that's the that's the bill Mr
chairman and a little bit of the context
and uh we have some folks here from
community college system and from
Department of Corrections and uh you can
focus in on some of those things with
them but I'm be glad to answer any
questions you have
now thank
you could you tell me um how this what
how this came out of the Senate what was
the the vote did it come out unanimously
was this Clos oh very good excellent um
further questions for the senator
representative wheeler thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question Senator Waters um my first
question has to do with I'm on page two
line uh 18 where it's talking about the
c vbg c
vpg
uh what they shall do and it says
especially in coordination with the
England Board of higher education do you
mean New England board thank you for
correction of typo all the Senate eyes
that looked on that I figured you
know we want to slip one in to go
International on us can I ask a follow
up Mr chairman and I'm an English
Professor you know there you go thank
you representative wheer absolutely at
what point will Oxford be involved in
this goad represent um thank you Mr
chairman my followup uh has to do with
uh page one line 17 where you state that
a for formerly incarcerated person
appointed by the director of
rehabilitative services um uh will be a
part of this and I just was wondering
what you think the criteria that the
director will use to choose that person
will be well thank you for the question
and I'll answer it in two ways I mean
Nick is here and he can he can tell you
um but I I I think this is important in
part because of the experience that we
had on the England Board of higher
education uh commission where there were
were quite a quite a number of formally
incarcerated folks and um you know such
a range of people who had gotten out
started very successful businesses um or
you know doing other interesting things
with their lives and they could talk
very directly to the impacts but also
what programs
worked uh you know in the incarcerated
setting what what do they need what what
worked um and the message we got loud
and clear is we want things that really
can can contribute to our being
able to get out into the world and have
a have a good job um and so that that
was very important to hear and the gamut
of people um what they studied you know
from some social work to uh
Finance um
psychology uh you know the commissioner
of Department of Corrections uh Hanks
wanted us to change the title of this to
include vocational which is good
um so anyways I think that's that's what
can be contributed here and the criteria
um you know what I had imagined and
discussed on this was it would be
someone who had participated in um
educational programs um while
incarcerated uh and then otherwise I
think Nick Duffy can tell you because
he's the person who you know handles
Post Release and Post
Release represent Mar thank you for
taking my question um current certainly
um residents could take classes while
incarcerated and pay per credit um and I
just wonder what's going to happen when
the uh grant money does dry up is this
going to be a tax a burden for the
taxpayers thanks for the question um
unless the the Congress
repeals the eligibility for pel Grants
this funding will be available for the
foreseeable future so it's like pel
grants in general it it's you know the
pel grant program has been around for a
long time been funded for a long time um
so that's that's that's what's driving
this now the the grants and things I
think are kind of startup
funding um and uh you know that's why on
page two um you know consider I think
the question you raised a good one you
know what about the taxpayer and that's
why I put on um line 16 on page two to
we really to hear from this group just
that answer to your question and uh how
do we how do we plan for it but I think
the federal money is pretty
secure for as long as there's pel grants
in the future um but any if there are
any additional costs we got to we got to
get a hand on it and to be clear this
legislation doesn't commit us to
spending any money it just would commits
them to telling us if they need money
and why is that correct thank you Mr
chairman this you know like most of
these if this is coordination
and
study that's what the bill
is see no further questions thank you
Senator thank you very
much and the chair calls Joe
hos
good morning Mr chairman members of the
committee my name is Joe HW I live in
gilmington I put my post office box on
my pink card and I put three minutes and
I have three items I'd like to talk
about and number one is
uh page one line number
22 where it says other and then it has
the word corrections but before that it
has a higher education
so after the word education should be
like County houses of
Correction the superintendent uh should
be included I think in order to have
that other for Corrections because
there's no Corrections before that in
that uh paragraph Roman numeral
3 and uh line number 19 above that where
you have
OPC that's office of professional lure
that's currently
uh headed by Lindsey Courtney the
attorney Michael Courtney's wife he's up
in Hatfield she's working over there and
I'd like to add in there maybe
o the oplc director in good standing and
when I say good standing because I was
over there yesterday and I have a real
estate uh complaint there of June
2022 they take up to a year to
investigate it took 14 months for a
decision and it took another 6 months
for the decision to be sent to me that's
ridiculous and even the uh chairman over
there Mr Valentine he says we got to get
this backlog dealt with it's just like
the Human Rights Commission I don't know
if you heard about that or not but uh
she asked for four more investigators
Governor sununu said I'm going to give
you three she said no no I need four so
she got four and there shouldn't be a
backlog to begin with I just am upset
that uh you know you just presume that
the executive director isn't good
standing over there I just that's my you
know beef with uh the process over there
it's not uh it's free there no no charge
for a filing fee for a complaint but
it's not complete and it's not you know
article 14 free complete impr prompt my
Bill of Rights it's not and my last
Point number three is on page
two uh line
16 uh where it says f Federal funding
and I'd like to add in uh just like the
uh let me give you an example first the
US uh Marshall over there at the federal
building it says his oath of office is
to execute lawful precepts and I saw
the US Marshall woman over there
yesterday I said well what does that
mean does that mean that some are
unlawful and uh you know I won't get
into all the detail but I just would
like to put in there before the word
federal legal and lawful Federal funding
because this state operates I was told
by Bob
G him former Senator he he told danan
Richard who told me he said the state
operates on 40% Federal funding so
unless that Federal funding comes in a
lot of these state things aren't going
to be done and I'm really upset with the
feds I mean uh if somebody owes money
like on a
tax do they have a course with X number
of classes in that subject matter of
incarceration my friend Ed Brown over in
planfield he was arrested and sent to
the FCI federal correctional institute
the word correction is uh you know you
have courses with classes there are none
in his subject matter and it's it was
Judge Nathan Clifford of the US Supreme
Court he was born in rney New Hampshire
in 1875 he put it on the books the
morsel case he said you squeeze the
Creditor down to half their freeold and
make them pay from that uh estate their
their uh their Homestead you use he they
use the tools of their trade you don't
just send somebody to prison and send
you and me the bill for their upkeep I'm
very obset with you know there's a lot
of Education stuff in here but not too
much on correction thank
you thank you for sharing your thoughts
with us today um the chair recognizes
Shannon
Reed good morning uh Miss chairman and
members of the committee my name is
Shannon Reed I'm here representing the
community college system of New
Hampshire um a couple years ago a couple
of our institutions were approved for um
sites campuses to offer Second Chance p
uh prison education programs we
currently are working with um students
in the northern New Hampshire
Correctional Facility um our campus up
in Berlin New Hampshire white Mounds
Community College is the campus that is
offering those programs
the the initial group of students
started about a year ago in March taking
classes in um business administration
and liberal arts programs working toward
their associate
degree um we have um been working
closely also with our colleagues at the
University system of New Hampshire to
work on transfer Pathways for those
students when they complete their
Associate Degree for those who wish to
to continue their education at the B at
the Balor level and we are also grateful
for the partnership with the Department
of Corrections on this on this um
program and area offering prison
education programming is not without
challenges so the idea of a Planning
Group that can bring together uh
relevant stakeholders is is a is a very
um good and useful beneficial idea
matters like um coordinating planning
and evaluation and looking at what can
be available for resources are matters
that this group could um could work on
together effectively um Senator Waters
mentioned one of the sort of attributes
or or out expected outcomes of of prison
education and one of them is
self-efficacy and I'd like to just share
a brief story um with with the cohort of
students that we were working with at up
at White Mountains Community College at
the Northern New Hampshire Correctional
Facility they they they told a story
where um they tried to advocate for
something a few months a few months
before the program started I think it
was additional recreational time and it
didn't go very well their attempts to
Advocate but they said after we took our
first college composition course and we
learned things like how to communicate
differently how to communicate more
effectively and then they went back and
they tried again and they were
successful that time um in getting what
what they what they needed and so not
only does this type of of of Program
help incarcerated individuals Post
relase in getting um employment and um
avoiding you know recidivism but it also
helps them to kind of learn and practice
those skills while they're still inside
the walls and and maybe improve their
their lives there and create a safer
environment so we're very supportive of
this bill um we thank the sponsor for um
engaging Us in its Drafting and um we
look forward to working as part of this
task force if if this bill does get pass
and enacted and I'm happy to take any
questions representative
Muse one thing I'm just guessing is that
uh can't offer all of your curriculum uh
to to folks so how do you how do you
make that decision or is that something
you're looking for uh guidance
on I would I would I would say that um
there are a lot of issues that have to
do with things like first all faculty
who are who are available and willing to
teach you know within a prison setting
um things like equipment and technology
that can or can't be used in a prison
settings so those are some of the
considerations um I I might heard it Mr
Duffy from the Department to be a little
more specific about that I myself am not
directly involved in the program so I
might not have all the details that
folks would be looking
for further
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony chair calls Mr Nicholas
stuffy
good on now thank you for allowing me to
speak today um my name is Nick Duffy I'm
the director of rehability of services
for the New Hampshire Department of
Corrections um again uh as Senator
Waters was um mentioning uh education is
extremely important um for for in
individuals incarcerated from making
sure that they have the skills needed
upon release um it helps lower
recidivism there's study after study
that shows just how important that um
education is and then the higher level
of Education that somebody can get while
incarcerated um means that that level of
recidivism continues to decrease so with
each degree level of recidivism drops
drastically and that um is through the
Rand study um that uh that information
is so you can look that up
um
uh we we believe that this um this
committee would be extremely beneficial
um although we are doing these
connections now and having some of this
these conversations but bringing this
together with specific goals in mind in
order to uh not just the Department of
Corrections having those conversations
individually with each of these groups
with all the groups coming together
there's a lot of resources ideas each
state is doing things a little bit
differently um and so collectively
coming together and having these
conversations and figuring out how to
for long-term sustainability to make
sure that um it just isn't put on the
taxpayer to pay for um programming or um
or the residents to try to find a way to
um pay for this themselves but a way
that we can find um long-term
sustainability keep costs down and
provide as much education as we can um
during their
incarceration thank you I'm willing to
take any questions you have at this time
representative Cel thank you and thank
you for taking my question I'm wondering
if you might be able to share with us a
unexpected success story from one of
your uh someone who who participated in
this kind of a program yeah so I think
that there's a lot of um success stories
that I could probably uh draw from but
overall I think there's you know there
was a couple years ago one of our high
school graduations um you know it there
was a individual who was struggling to
sort of keep up with his high school
education um and his son was going to
drop out of school and he said that he
basically came up with an agreement with
his son you stay in I'll stay in and so
they completed together um and I think
that's the kind of thing is it's it's
not just even about them but it's about
generational incarceration and
generational um impacts at this has and
so the more that they can get and see
that okay my dad was able to do this or
mom was able to do this the more that um
that the their children can see okay now
this is I can do this as well so um
although that was a high school um
example I think that um it's it's it the
the example that they're setting for
their children the example they're
setting for um their own future and he
said it was a rough patch but that was
he was able to overcome it and and um
and uh has been extremely successful
since
so as part of the work product for this
group will it be um kind of a a a sort
of um public relations type thing
whereas you're going to show the the
return on investment to be able to so
that whatever portion does end up coming
from Public Funding that the cost
benefit is it weighs in favor of helping
with the education versus further en
eration given the the current public um
issues regarding student loan debt I
feel like there will be some people
saying wait a minute why why are we
doing this and the mine's not getting
paid to show them well actually it saves
you money by doing this that type of
thing yeah absolutely and I think that's
where grants are really helpful because
they can show the success of something
then say well yes it might cost a little
bit more long term for us but this
investment can save us so much more um
down the road and I think that's really
what we need to show this is is not just
about um doing it but is it working and
we don't want to have programs that
aren't working and and just sort of
waste of money this we know that um
these types of Investments has shown to
be successful but we need to show it
successful within our within our own
programs as well and bring that data
forward and and say in our reports and
and what we're reporting this is what
the impact has been very good thank you
representative
n
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question um last year in a
hearing about um
sentencing uh we were talking about
essentially what would commonly be known
as you know time off for good behavior
um and one of the you know was a variety
of programs that you could go through uh
we had someone who came in and spoke to
um uh things like education being one of
those uh where the financial uh they did
not have the uh financial means to be
able to do that so I was wondering if
you could uh speak a little bit to the
way that this levels the playing field
for people to be able to um rather than
financial uh having a financial barrier
having it be based on uh Merit and their
determination and and what they do with
it so currently with um with uh earn
time credit is that uh there is already
that in place where they depending on
the degree they get they can get earn
time credit for um currently right now
um they would have to pay for those that
themselves unless they're participating
in our um our current pel um classes
so you're right is that somebody needs
the financial ability to be able to um
do the correspondence courses or um or
participate in that way this really
would be about um our current standards
are more about remaining um as doing the
right things remaining disciplinary free
making sure that you're um being a good
citizen within our our environment to be
selected for this um this program and so
there is a huge Advantage for us as well
just from a behavioral standpoint to get
people to do the right things in order
to go into this program um so in the in
that respect um somebody who has a
financial barrier to pay for higher ed
well that will remove that um Financial
barrier um again this committee itself
is really um uh we're already working
toward pel grants and we're already
doing pel grants and so that's already
happening I think um this committee is
really about ensuring long-term
sustainability of those
programs yeah thank you
represent BR thank you Mr chairman um
just trying to look at it real quickly
so if it's in here and I and I passed it
up please um excuse that is would this
be effective for every person regardless
of if whether it's a life sentence or
not uh
so uh pel you mean pel pel funding can
you get pel funding regardless of your
sentence the so the so the education
that is yeah that is being discussed
here yeah would that be available to to
every per to every inmate regardless of
the the sentence yeah so we we offer
education to anyone regardless of their
um of their sentence structure so
whether they um have a life sentence or
um they're going to be there various
amount of years however prior priority
is given to people who have um have less
time to to achieve that while
incarcerated so if somebody only has a
couple years um they would probably be
able to get into the program quicker if
there's weight list for that program um
because we want to make sure they can
get that um prior release um if there's
room in a program you know space
available in the program we do allow um
any sentence structure to um participate
and I think there is um data to show
that even for individuals who aren't
going to be released um there's benefits
to that um uh just institutional
behavior um and and other
factors see you on for other questions
thank you for your testimony thank you
so there anyone else wishing to testify
in this bill who was not signed up to do
so there being none that hereby close
public hearing I hereby open the public
hearing on Senate
Bill 48 no excuse me
322 and recognize senator induce the
bill well good morning members of the
House criminal justice committee it's
great to be here for the record my name
is Senator Howard Pearl I am the senator
from District 17 I live in the Great
town of Lowden I am here today to
introduce Senate Bill
322 this bill requires a licensing
Authority and excuse me this bill
requires a li license authorizing an IND
individual to carry a loaded pistol or
revolver in the state to include the
name title and signature of the person
issuing the license the bill further
provides immunity to law enforcement
officers who in good faith issue these
licenses under the RSA so the background
on this why I put this bill in which is
always important is a constituent came
to me with a situation where they had uh
received a license to carry and you know
as you recall back when we did
constitutional carry we left that
provision in that folks could get a
license so that if they wanted to carry
in other states they could enjoy
reciprocity and the individual that came
to me their their police chief would not
sign the license because they for
reasons that they had an issue with the
Constitutional carry itself not so much
the person you know not my constituent
but they just didn't want to sign any of
them because they felt that the
Constitutional carry provision had taken
away their ability to decide if someone
was suitable or not and only allowed the
federal prohibitions on whether they
could issue a
license so when that happened this now
leaves you excuse me you me anyone else
whose Chief decides that they didn't
want to sign the license with a a carry
license but it's not signed well that's
a potential problem if you're traveling
and you want to go to another
jurisdiction where they recognize our
license you know we have reciprocity
with them you get in a situation where
you get pulled over for whatever reason
you're now carrying a firearm with a
license to not signed that's a real
potential issue and so that was the
Genesis for me putting in this bill and
as you'll see all it does is it requires
that the uh issuing um municipality that
the officer who's issuing it that they
sign it and that they put their name
title and their signature on it now in
return U the we made sure I believe they
already had immunity from acting in
their capacity as an officer and doing
their official duty but just to be sure
we also included the IM Immunity Clause
in this bill to make sure that it was
very clear that they had no personal um
liability on on doing their job so that
is the uh nuts and bolts of the bill I
do have my constituent here today to
testify on the bill on as well so that
uh she was willing to come in and step
up and tell her story here as well so if
um you'll have an opportunity from here
to hear from her too if you have
specific um questions for her about the
Court situation that she went to to try
through to try and compel the uh the
signature on her license so with that I
will take any
questions thank you Senator so just for
the to be clear for the committee New
Hampshire is a sh issue state is that
that correct I'm sorry I didn't hear you
New Hampshire is a sh issue state is
that correct so a chief has no
discretion unless you are a prohibited
person by federal law they have to give
you the permit correct does the permit
have a space on it for the uh Chief
signature yes so they were not
completing the the form properly is what
what I'm hearing some of the chiefs were
put great question and thank you some of
the chiefs were putting per RSA rather
than their signature on it and boy I
don't know if I get pulled over in a
another state and I pull that out saying
I have a right to have a concealed
carryer I'm not sure that that would
give me the confidence I wouldn't end up
with some legal issues that I didn't
want yeah I I would hate to be in
Alabama trying to explain what RSA means
there you have it
uh representative Stone thank you thank
you for taking my question uh during
your research for this bill did you find
that this was an ongoing problem with
many agencies or just a handful of
agencies in New Hampshire I don't know
the exact number and that's a great
question but there are some I did work
with the uh the chief's Association and
worked with uh with them on trying to
craft a some language that would be
acceptable to them there's still some
resistance from some of the Chiefs but
they do understand that they have a duty
to do and uh that the giving you know
clear clearly spelling out that the uh
the immunity in this bill helped ease
some of the concerns that they had
follow
up in your opinion in the research
you've done isn't it uh kind of
obligated by their office of chief of
police to sign these forms if there's no
reason to deny a
license I felt that was the case but the
court and again I'll let my uh
constituent talk about her court case
and the Court ruling that came through
essentially my understanding is the
court uh said that you know they they
have to issue the license but it wasn't
clear that they had to sign it so we're
making it clear that they have to sign
it and that's what compelled this
legislation thank
you see no further questions thank you
for introducing the bill to us well
you're very welcome and thank you all
for the great work you're doing have a
great day yeah and the chair calls
Cheryl
Dean
good
morning
um well I'll just start my story um I
had already had a
signed um concealed carry permit issued
to me in
2015 and basically what I'm going to go
through is just the the court case and
then the judgment and I have copies for
everybody of both uh because the exhibit
there's exhibits and and if you um you
don't have to get into the detail if you
don't want you can just give us
basically the timeline on what happened
and what the judge said yeah I'm going
to give you the reader's dive just for
and if you want to hand out more
in-depth stuff for us to read we'd be
happy to take it okay um so I did have a
ass signed permit and there is a picture
of it in here um I went to renew it um
and that was after conceal uh
constitutional carry had passed so that
was in
2019 um nothing had changed I'm not a
prohibited person I'm actually a
certified NRA instructor as well as a
range safety officer I have a ton of
certificates um and I'm highly
trained so when I went to uh go get it
in 2019 I picked it
up um and instead of it looking like the
one that I had before
um it
said uh where it has authorized
signature it says per RSA
-6 um so I question it because of it not
being a signature and there is no title
given on there um I do travel to other
states um and like you said before I
don't want to have to explain something
in
Alabama because it just doesn't look
like it's filled out um so so I went
back and I was like you know to the
chief I'm like what is this and he's
like well per constitutional carry
passing um I I'm not signing any of them
so I was like oh great um in addition to
that there was an issue too um he didn't
issue it for the correct number of years
um so I got an attorney um the attorney
contacted him we got another um pistol
revolver license that had the correct
number of years but he still refused to
sign it um he worked with my attorney a
little bit um so it actually went to
court um and the judge found that RSA
1596 does not require Chief signature in
order for the license to be validly
issued however he must include his name
as chief of police of northward as it is
the chief who has the authority to issue
such licenses not the police department
generally so
um basically what she said that the RSA
needs to be fixed uh because there is
nothing in the RSA currently
that says he has to sign it so I did get
another one it has his um title on it
but it still says P
RSA so all I'm looking for is to have my
PRL look like everybody else's and not
give I get a hairy eyebrow when I do
have to show
it is he currently still the chief yes I
see okay and are you aware of any other
um in your experience working with
firearms and things are you aware of any
other Chiefs that are doing this is this
some kind of a movement or what it's
it's not just my chief there are others
um uh my attorney Evan napen he was
working with a couple other people or
had spoken to a couple other people at
the time so I know wasn't just
Northwood further
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony okay where do I um if you hand
it out down at the end there they'll
pass it around if you have one for
everyone thank you anyone else wishing
to testify on this spill see in Nana
here by Clos public
hearing the next public hearing will
start at 12 no 1:00 so we're on break
until 1:00
all
right
e
good afternoon everybody I hope you
enjoyed your
lunch uh it is
1:00 um so we are going to open up our
afternoon hearings and I would just like
to remind everybody before We Begin that
looking at our agenda it would appear
that several of our bills may end up
being a little bit controversial so I
would just like to remind the committee
um if you're going to ask a question
please just remember to keep your
opinions for the executive session and
just please remember to State the
question from the get-go that would be
helpful and we recognize Senator abbis
to introduce his
bill
good afternoon everyone uh Senator Daryl
abbis I represent District 22 I serving
the communities of Pelham Salem aent and
plastow I'm here to introduce Senate
Bill
248 as the prime sponsor this language
may look very familiar as Senate Bill
252 that this committee passed I know
there was some amendments there but
there were two the two Senate bills
filed at the same time we felt it was
important to one on the poliy alone was
worth passing it again out of the Senate
but also um without knowing when we did
pass it we weren't sure what the status
of the um Senate Bill 252 would have
been but those the original Bill the
languages are identical there is a
actual uh Gap in the bail system the
bail laws right now the
procedure if someone is arrested and if
there's a I guess if the state would
like to request a dangerousness hearing
or have someone held because they
believe them to be a threat to
themselves or to the public they they
can request that hearing but it has to
be done uh it's a 48 hour notice so in
theory this person could be held to be a
danger to themsel or someone else
however they've been
released uh into the public or been
released by a bail commissioner before
that hearing would ever happen uh so if
you look at the list of offenses and
they're all all the offenses listed all
of them are there the two types of
crimes a violent crime with the victim
is a human being or it's a sex crime
against a
child those are the crimes all listed
all of those are egregious
offenses uh I hope you leave all those
in there because uh they are all serious
offenses many of those offenses are
elevating offenses uh some of those are
crimes where the victim never recovers
uh particularly child
pornography that image never goes away
once it's out there it's out there and
the courts have been very consistent
when you support that market by simply
possessing the the material you're
encouraging the the activity a lot of
that is a lot of those um Productions
are made overseas so we can't always
necessarily stop that but we certainly
don't have to support the market uh also
many individuals um who are charged with
that are considered to be dangerous
because one they're they tend to not be
willing to serve out the offense you had
an issue in Florida where the federal
government was executing an arrest
warrant uh for child pornography and two
agents were uh actually shot through the
door and died so these type of offenses
all it's going to do is they're going to
be held and we're not saying bail
Commissioners are doing a bad job but
they're going to be held until they're
brought before a judge I understand
there's a desire or appetite for
magistrates uh that's something that's
you know a work in progress but in the
meantime uh we shouldn't jeopardize
Public Safety while we work that
procedure
out I think this this is an opportunity
for us to do the right thing and fix
that procedural Gap and I hope you all
support the ought to pass I'll answer
any
questions representative scitec isn't
this duplicative you you I thought you
said that so why are we why are we
passing this if two 318 for example well
well stting the obvious I I like my
version the bill that I file better than
the other one I wish I filed first by
the way but it but but that aside uh I
believe the bill was actually amended
Senate Bill 252 so this kind of gives
you a chance to reconsider whatever was
done in that also uh when we bid pass
this we weren't all clear what would
actually the outcome of that would
be um I think part of the change was to
change domestic violence to
felony domestic violence can you live
with that as opposed to
misdemeanor
um sexual domestic
violence can I ask for clar is that the
only offense that you want to remove I
want to remove them all but I think this
is probably the most reasonable one
because I in my view I think a bail
commissioner would probably not release
any I would not release any of these
people I and I don't need the law to
tell me that because I recog recogniz
that there are danger I don't want to
preach the one that is most that is so
routine I've done 500 I'm picking it and
I'm not wrong by much misdemeanor uh
domestic violence where somebody slams
the door pulls a phone off the wall uh
throws something and you
know there's no real uh no real assault
No Bottle injury no I didn't say I'm not
forgiving
or saying it's not serious but it's a
misdemeanor crime not a felony he didn't
grab her by the throat throw her around
that sort of
thing so so I'm looking to can you my
question is can you live with
misdemeanor
um leaving in misdemeanor domestic
violence so I I wish every bail
commissioner would take the position you
you are you're taking but obviously we
can't we can't do
that it's a tough pillow to swallow
someone who's represented both victims
of domestic violence and people who have
committed horrible
crimes domestic violence tends to
escalate it's Al Al also one of the most
underreported crimes out there so my
experience working on the ground level
in interacting with indiv idual
individuals without getting into those
details I I would strongly strongly
recommend against that with that being
said would I would I support the whole
bill go not passing IID have to think
about it but when I when I say when you
said if no assault
happens if no assault happens there's no
domestic violence it's because that
whatever conduct they engaged in put
that person in fear for their safety and
and that's the that's one of the
standards so if they're ripping a phone
off the wall and and making you know
threats on top of that and this is an
escalating
situation I would I would I would uh be
cautious of of ignoring
that we had a case in this state where a
person was arrested for domestic
violence was released by Bill
commissioner and then that that same
within that night went to the victim's
house broke in and sexually assaulted
her while her child was in the room so
again escalating
offenses we're trying to address the
most
egregious situations that arose from
bail reform Without Really backtracking
or erasing the whole
system rep representative scitec I I
feel like we're getting down into an
argumentative path so is this that's
exactly what it's going to say I'm not I
don't want to debate it but it would be
fine thank you representative Murray
thank you madam chair repres stices a
friend by the
way um so if I remember correctly the
way we amend and I was on the bail
subcommittee so the way we amended
s252 was to remove like representative
scitech is saying the misdemeanor level
of domestic violence um but we also um
lowered the standard for um like
dangerousness to the public so instead
of it being
um uh it's basically between
preponderance of the evidence and clear
and convincing evidence um so it also
makes it easier for them to hold someone
um if they are considered a danger to
the public I'm just wondering if you've
had a chance to review the bill and like
have um any yeah thoughts on if this is
really needed with the compromise we
already arrived to as a
house so that it's now the legal
standard in between clear and convincing
evidence in preponderance of evidence I
it's a substantial evidence which is
supposed to be yeah between those
two I suppose if you want to articulate
a fact pattern to decipher between th
what would meet one and not the other I
understand lowering the burden I think
the burden of proof is really it's I I
think it's important that the state if
they want someone to be
held you know in pre-trial detention
they should meet their burden of clear
and convincing evidence I think that's
fair because person hasn't been
convicted I mean there is two sides of
it but when someone's charged with a
violent offense with whe the victims a
person or sex crimes against children
all I'm asking is that that bail hearing
they be held and can be overnight it can
be for a day or two that's how that's
just how our system is right now I I
would prefer that to be in front of a
judge because what happens is when
people are released by a bill
commissioner the practice is that they
wave their arraignment and then that
person is not going to be in court for
quite some time so all this is that's
really what we're trying to do is is get
this person in front of a judge that's
it's not even to say the state is going
to ask for the person to be held on
pre-trial detention that they may agree
to personal recog that's up to the the
prosecutor on that particular case if
they want to go forward with that
hearing and the person is held then that
the defendant would be able to then
challenge that I the procedure is
already in the law for that I believe
it's 48 hours at a that's that's the
minimum I mean uh excuse me the maximum
time they would have to wait unless they
requested more
but more importantly to me is that it's
not saying that no matter what they're
going to be held so I think keeping the
higher standards appropriate for know
constitutional issues or like Liberty
arguments but at the same time I don't
see the harm in them being brought
before a
judge thank you for answering my
question um and thank you and
um uh so to to be clear the reason why
you think this bill UMB 320 or SP 248 is
necessary is because we don't know how
the magistrate thing is going to play
out and we need to address these issues
right now um I guess one concern I'd
bring before you that we heard um during
the subcommittee is the public defenders
um talking about just their own capacity
to because when it goes before a judge
then they are required to have um an
attorney a public defender assigned to
them and under that timeline it can be
kind of hard and then the capacity um
increases so I'm just curious if you
talked with them or if you've heard
anything about their almost inability to
potentially be able to meet this
standard because of um the increase in
public defenders that would need to be
brought in at an earlier point in these
cases so I think the the amount of uh
hearings per day we did the math last
term so my numbers are a little bit
outdated uh in the sense that they from
more
2022 but uh I think it was about around
20 to 25 per day throughout the entire
state
I understand that some areas be more
populated but they also have more
funding for legal aid in those areas uh
there are some legislation that's you
know out there to increase funding for
legal aid they're underfunded either way
by the way so just keep that in mind
that if that comes up in future budgets
but they haven't brought that attention
to me but Public Safety is Public Safety
I understand that they may be meeting
that client for the first time that day
and if it doesn't go well and the person
you know is not uh not released they can
ask for another hearing with within you
know a few days to get more evidence and
they can even have witnesses come in so
and that cuts both ways because if the
prosecutor is asking them them be held
quite often the prosecutor is also just
getting that file that day because the
person was just arrest unless it's an
arrest due to an
indictment representative Harry
cther you're you're good representative
Willer thank you madam chair
thank you for taking my question Senator
abbis to hone in on what representative
Murray was saying it just feels a little
bit like Groundhog Day here when we're
seeing this bill again and I'm wondering
why why file this bill if we're in the
process of the houses passed on the
consent calendar a number of bail bills
in the finance committee has taken them
up in a way which suggests their passing
and and being moved to your body uh in
which case you would have the
opportunity to amend those and bring
them back to us and I'm I'm a little
curious as to why we're creating another
vehicle for this issue to be dealt with
in the middle of the bium so first I
filed I filed this bill before the other
one it just that's just how how it
worked out 248 just just beat my my good
friend from from Manchester to the punch
who was sent a bill 252 I and I I did
ask uh her to co-sponsor this but I
think it just kind of got lost in
Shuffle so the two bills were the exact
identical language um I let my I agreed
in gave the blessing and I testify in
support of Senator susi's Bill passing
uh last year but we kept this and we
re-referred it and held on to it again
without knowing the result of the bill
uh the magistrate bill it never hurts to
have two vehicles going in case one
falls apart which can happen based on
attendance I'm sure this this body's
learned it all too well this term uh so
regardless the way you fall on that it
does not hurt to have two but I also
think that they're different because if
the Magistrate um you know Provisions
don't go forward then you can at least
evaluate this on its own form without
the magistrate system but and maybe
perhaps consider which offenses you want
to leave in I would recommend leaving
them all in but you know that's that's a
different conversation to
have I'm
also representative wheeler there's
nobody you can trust better than just
yourself so I might be the reason why
people want to make sure that they're
good to go
I believe you had a competing bill as
well that you kind of get lost in the
Lost in the shuffle just
happens representative
Muse
so just to sum up um one way to think of
your bill is as the kind of the before
Bill uh and Senator susi's Bill s252 is
kind of the after
Bill well I I would say if you pass them
both and sign them both into law they
will from what I understand would
conflict with each other so that would
be ill
advised but I I think assuming one will
pass and one won't I would also be ill
advised so I think if one does not pass
and does not make it over the Finish
Line this this is another vehicle to
consider because it does address I think
a procedural Gap in the the process I
can't imagine someone's charged with you
know a discussing crime sex crime
against a child and the state wants that
person to be held you know not released
you know pending their trial because
it's a very egregious offense and we
have to get into the specific facts of
what that would be the person could be
released awaiting that hearing which
that if this is a public safety concern
the person is actually found to be
dangerous and there's sufficient
evidence of that it just seems odd that
that that procedural Gap is there this
addresses that does this solve the
entire problems of bail it no but it's I
think to
start thank
you looks like nobody else wants to ask
anything Senator you're
free thank you madam chair thank you for
coming in I'm going to be here all
day David
Rothstein
uh good afternoon my name is David
Rothstein um I'm here uh on behalf of
the New Hampshire Association of
criminal defense lawyers and speaking in
in opposition to this um this particular
Senate Bill 248 and sitting here and in
talking to Professor Sher beforehand I'm
gathering there's a lot of other moving
Parts uh with respect to this issue and
with respect to this bill so some of
what I say may not really matter if
there's other packages or Bills moving
forward but I'm here so for what it's
worth I'll say what I came to say um
this bill um and potentially another one
that's move further in the process
purports to separate out certain
offenses for differential treatment
based upon uh the nature of the offense
uh alone the the title of the offense uh
in the criminal code um that is not
unprecedented the federal system uh does
this with respect to bail um in the
federal system there are a number of
offenses that are segregated and treated
differently and pushed further more
toward a presumption of detention with
respect to bail um for the most part
these are mandatory minimum firearm
offenses uh cases where there's a
destructive device used terrorism uh
offenses very serious drug offenses also
offenses in the federal system that are
punished Able by up to life or death
such as treason uh aircraft piracy or or
homicide um so the the list and it also
I I will say the federal list does
include crimes against minors which this
list also purports to include but for
the most part we're talking about some
of the most serious offenses that we
know or that we hear of we're talking
about Timothy McVey we're talking about
people who have a very large amount of
fentanyl or Methamphetamine facing very
very ser serous time in prison otherwise
the federal system tends to favor uh
pre-trial release the federal system um
is supported by a very robust pre-trial
release system where there's a report
done on basically every single defendant
that comes into the court and also um a
pre-trial supervision system that's
tailored to the circumstances of the
individual
offender um so what what's discussed
here is not without precedent but I
think the Federalist and the federal
system is is different in a couple
respects
this separation of uh offenses for
treatment on bail is also not without
president in our very bail statute under
RSA
5971 uh small C there is differential
treat differential treatment already for
those offenders who are accused of an
offense which is punishable by up to
life in prison in those situations it is
uh there's a whole different system set
forth in the statute um there is a very
major burden um that has to be met a
much more significant burden that has to
be met for a person facing uh a life
sentence than there is for any other
type of crime so we do already have that
um in our criminal code in our bail
statute for people who are charged with
the most serious
offenses so here we're talking about um
some offenses that are serious and I
don't mean to suggest otherwise but are
not on the order of homicide so we have
a list and when we have a list there's
typically a commonality among the items
on the list but this list lists it has
homicide at the head of the list um and
it has a number of other uh types of
crimes that um in in my view and in the
view of the criminal code are not
reasonably comparable in terms of the
penalty and in terms of the ultimate
sentence that a person is likely to
serve as you probably know um and as I
know well from defending many people
charged with homicide uh those people
generally get convicted the cases are
charged by the Attorney General's office
they're generally very strong cases um
if they do not serve life without parole
The Plea Bargains involved tend to
involve decades uh in in prison so as a
practical matter if this person is
charged with first deegree murder second
degree murder um they are going to serve
a very long time in prison there's a
statute that recognizes that and makes
it nearly impossible for them to get out
of jail and I think as a system and as a
defense attorney I expect that my client
is going to be held and is probably
going to serve a very long sentence so
homicide I think is the Apex in terms of
danger in terms of risk of flight um in
terms of the probability of a person um
being convicted and serving a very long
sentence but many of the offenses here
it's been pointed out that misdemeanor
domestic violence is on this list but
even other offenses frankly first degree
assault many second degree assaults that
are on this list they're often resolved
uh with no or little incarceration um
sometimes reduced to misdemeanor
sometimes they end up being dropped um
altogether which is a a devastating
consequence uh for a person who is uh
held pre-trial potentially more likely
to be held due to a
presumption and a person who's charged
I'm just going to pick on second deegree
assault um is not necessarily more
dangerous to the alleged victim not
necessarily more dangerous to the public
not necessarily any less amenable to
release than a person who's charged with
DWI operating after certification as a
bital offender or burglary but maybe
they are and this is this is what um
judges prosecutors and defense attorneys
do every day I will assure you that when
a person is before a bail commissioner
when a person is before a judge that
judicial officer that bail commissioner
absolutely considers the nature of the
offense the gersting affidavit um the
probable cause affidavit that may be
before him or her if someone is charged
with first degree assault a light bulb
goes off if someone is charged with
forgery maybe you know maybe there's a
more of a presumption of release
especially if the person doesn't have a
record so I do think this is something
that is already very seriously being
considered um I do not think that a lot
of these uh offenses belong on the same
list as as homicide um with respect to
offenses against children which are as
abhorent and and viewed as as abhorent
as homicide and in many respects and for
good reasons um currently I will tell
you that there are people charged with
aggravated fluous sexual assault who are
released on bail there are people who
are not and the same thing with child
pornography and there's a lot that goes
into that sort of calculus um maybe the
sexual assault occurred a very long time
ago maybe it was an isolated incident
maybe this person otherwise has baale
facts that um make them amenable to
release in the community same thing with
the so-called child pornography maybe it
was one or two images maybe it's an
especially young or an especially old
person um I think all of these things
are taken into consideration already so
just in some I I think that that our
statutory scheme um already sorts things
out appropriately I think that the
actors in the scheme um can um make
these assessments we're not always going
to agree with these assessments and
there's always with bail going to be a
story that can be told about something
that happened and there's not a lot we
can do about that unless we just lock
everyone up pre-trial can happen um in
any respect um so for those reasons I
would uh just offer my comments uh in
opposition to this list and and this
type of segregation based on offense
alone thank
you representative
Newman
this bill as I read it thank you madam
chair this bill as I read it um prevents
bail commissioner that on on the off
hour the off hours of of the
Court um the these this list prevents
any of
these um crimes to be heard by a bail
commissioner so you no matter how they
keep making it smaller and smaller
bigger and bigger do you do you think do
you
find um concern about the elimination of
bail commissioners before
we get something else that will take
care of the auth hours like the
magistrate bill or the judges I my
understanding and again from talking to
Professor sh my understanding is that
there is and I've read a bit about um a
magistrate initiative that is in effect
or that is progressing um I've spoken
before um about bail Commissioners um
bail Commissioners have been in our
system for a very long time um I I think
bail Commissioners are they're capable
of exercising their judgment they're
capable of exercising their common sense
um and and looking at um the information
they have to make the determinations
that they make to have off hours that
being said I always think that we can do
a better job I think judges can do a
better job in the federal system when a
judge makes a bail to determination he's
got a probation officer who wrote a
whole report uh to guide him or her in
making the decision um so I'm not I'm
not sure I'm hitting on on the center of
your question um I think that that more
training or potentially magistrates is
potentially better but I I'm I mean I
from my position I have confidence in in
in bail Commissioners exercising their
discretion with respect to any offense
that comes before them
thank
you we hear often in this testimony
because this is we've had testimony on
bills like this for year for as long as
I've been here and and this is my third
time around um but there's always a
premise that's made that the bail
commission that the
judges they the bail commissioner don't
do as good a job it's judges and more
people get released have have have you
found that premise that that bail
Commissioners release more people to uh
than judges or I what's your opinion on
that yeah I I I certainly do not have
any sort of numbers my my impression is
that that's not the case I mean it would
be as as you probably know if you've sat
through number of these bills our system
is is a great system but it's it's not
it's very deficient in terms of
collecting any sort of information I
don't know if states do I I do not have
an impression that bail Commissioners
are more permissive in relacing people
than um judges are in fact I wouldn't I
I think there probably are a number of
different types of bail Commissioners in
terms of the backgrounds they come from
um I wouldn't be surprised if it were
more the opposite where a bail
commissioner is going to say this is a
first-degree assault I don't know very
much about the this person um I'm not
really liking what I hear about them
they're going to get a hearing in in a
short period of time I'm going to be
more cautious and I'm going to I'm going
to hold them or I'm going to set a high
build I wouldn't be surprised if in
other words I wouldn't be surprised if
the opposite were in many cases
true thank
you if if I may ask a question so you
had mentioned about isolated incidences
and when you had mentioned that you were
um talking about um sexual assaults
specifically
so if a person has this isolated
incident or it may be thought that it is
there really isn't a way for New
Hampshire to know if it indeed is
isolated correct if a well correct I
mean if you have a person there's all
different you should I should I finish
the answer if not then I
won't you can but that was why just want
to know that there's there's not really
a way to know if you're right I mean
there's all different types of charging
decisions that are made
right there are different type oh okay
thank you oh I'm sorry there are
different types of charging decisions
that are made and they're made after
careful investigation typically there's
a Child Advocacy Center interview that's
done a forensic interview where a child
is interviewed um there are detectives
involved who have specialized training
so there's an effort if somebody if
somebody is charged with a single kind
of sexual assault there is an effort to
determine in from a from an
investigative perspective and aeren
forensic interviewing perspective what
you have do you have a person who
committed an isolated incident do you
have a pattern of sexual assault where
you have a girl who's been groomed and
sexually assaulted for years do you have
multiple victims this is something that
I I think investigators are always
looking at and I think they're getting
better and better at at at doing it um
and when they bring a case before the
court sometimes there's one indictment
sometimes there's 50
indictments that that presumably is
going to make a difference in in in in
baale I would
think okay
sure thank you very okay thank
you afternoon everybody uh for the
record my name is Albert Sher uh I'm a
law professor at uh Franklin Pi Law
Center and a Police Commissioner in
Portsmouth uh what I say here today is
my opinion only not that of either UNH
or the Portsmouth police commission
um I I know this committee spent
subcommittee and much of the committee
spent three months last fall going
through um all the permutations of bail
and trying to put in place Common Sense
practical uh changes that address the
concerns of all the stakeholders who
came in front of the the committee and
in fact all the stakeholders came in
front of the committee and um came up
with a package of bills that are making
their right
uh all of them have made it through the
the house the substance of the bills uh
I think a couple of them are in house
finance my understanding they're going
to make their way through house finance
relatively shortly and head to the
Senate
um I I think the danger from now on in
the package that uh this committee put
together after a lot of work is that one
legislature legislator or another is
going to see a thread that they think
they can improve if they pull that
thread and put another one in they can
make the package that this committee so
carefully put together over three months
of hearings they can make it better
um and I think this committee knows as
better than anyone now once you start
pulling those
threads um the whole thing might unravel
you know there were
everybody who testified prosecutors the
police Chiefs uh the public defender
program uh myself uh many other
superintendent uh bail
Commissioners um every body recognized
that what this committee came up with
involved a set of compromises on
everybody's
part you know uh and uh I think thread
pulling is the biggest danger to
something that was carefully crafted and
pulling one thread May unravel the whole
thing um you know I was and
and I think this committee will
understand the significance of what I'm
about to say say you know I'm in support
of this compromise and when I was in
house finance last week the executive
director of the police Chiefs
Association got up and said that the
police Chiefs Association was in
wholehearted support of the compromise
what I call the Grand bargain um so I
don't you know you can quibble this way
or that way whether Senator ab's Bill
improves something that matters to him I
don't think it does I think everything
that is in his bill is in uh the
compromise Bill and more I think it's
better um than this is and so I really
strongly recommend that this committee
interim study Senator ais's Bill and if
for some reason Things Fall Apart in the
Senate uh then we can pull Senator
avis's Bill back if need be and address
it but um let's
let's not be distracted by a particular
thread that one legislator or another
doesn't
like thank you attorney representative
Newman thank you madam chair thank you
for taking my
question this compromise that you speak
of that's on its way um does it does
this solve the problem that occurs when
you take bail Commissioners away or is
there something something would the bail
commission is remain in the interim or
or would there be a blank now because
like this bill that they would also take
away the bail Commissioners so um to
great question and captures the
multi-layered approach of the grand
bargain the compromise
Bill compromise bill says identifies 12
crimes they're all felonies a little
different than what's in Senator avis's
Bill but and it says uh they will be
held without seeing a bail
commissioner but they must see a
magistrate within 24 hours or a judge
within 24 hours okay it doesn't the
compromise as a whole does not get rid
of bail Commissioners I know
representative site believes differently
but it doesn't get rid of bail
Commissioners in fact it raises the pay
of bail Commissioners and in fact it
requires that if the the defendant can't
pay the bail commissioner that the state
pays the bail commissioner so we do
better by bail Commissioners in the
compromise Bill than anyone has done for
all the years that I've been and some of
you on this committee know how many
years that is all the years that I've
been involved working with this
committee and other committees on bail
so uh I I want to get rid of the
misunderstanding that the the
compromise gets rid of bail
Commissioners on on certain crimes it
says it meets the needs
of police
departments who said during all the
hearings last year we don't like these
serious crimes going to bail
Commissioners because we don't trust
them and that's one of the reasons that
we put in place the the Magistrate
uh system a host of other reasons um so
uh it it takes care of that problem
thank you for refreshing my
memory thank
you is there anybody else that is here
that would like to testify on Senate
Bill 248 that is not turned in a pink
card see none I will close the public
hearing for our Senate Bill
in for Senate Bill 414 and we recognize
the
sponsor oh we representative Senator
abis to introduce the
Bill thank you madam chair members of
the committee Senator Daryl abis I
represent uh District 22 serving the
communities of pelum Salem ACC
plastow
uh I'm introducing this on behalf of
Senator Ganon uh what this does it
creates a mandatory minim minimum
sentence for someone uh who distributes
fentanyl or fentanyl class drug to
someone and it causes their death it's a
10-year mandatory minimum sentence uh
and they could actually serve up to a
life
imprisonment that's what the bill does
and I can answer any questions
representative
Balden thank you for taking my question
is it your belief that um
this penalty increase would make
it less likely that people would
overdose I couldn't speak on whether
they're less likely to overdose because
a synthetic drug like fentol is Con
constantly changing and being disguised
on the drugs but when it comes to
Distributing the drugs and you're going
to hand it to someone else and it's
going to kill someone I think someone
would be less likely to do that to know
that if they did that and it resulted in
a death because they're giving someone a
drug that has a high frequency of people
overdosing and dying they're going to
face a mandatory minimum of 10 years in
jail that's that's the best case
scenario so I think they would be less
people willing to take the risk of
Distributing it and I don't believe this
would really come up very often when you
have two addicts doing hand to hands
amongst themselves because and I'm sure
someone with law enforcement experience
could explain this better than I can but
generally it's hard to prove who gave
what to who when it's in that isolated
environment unless minus a
confession followup thank you um so it
then I take it it's your impression that
a mandatory minimum
would be known by people
Distributing drugs
and um they would be less likely to
distribute them I just trying to make
sense of how a mandatory minimum changes
Behavior over what we have today
considering that today there is a
penalty someone dies you are facing jail
time what does more jail time do to that
um mathematical situation well number
one they killed someone they did
something that they know could likely
cause the death of someone and then in
fact fact results in the death of
someone is it an intentional kill are
they intentionally killing the person I
I I'm not going to go that far but
they're they're giving someone an
illegal synthetic drug that they know
has a high propensity to lead to death
and they did it so perhaps what will
they know that they're going to face a
mandatory sentence I'm not I can't speak
to what a drug dealer would know but I'm
sure after the first person gets a
mandatory sentence it will be well known
within the criminal underworld and
it's I think it's something that would
we have people dying over 400 people
died of drug overdoses 80% of those were
Fentanyl and if you're going to give
that drug to someone and it's going to
kill
someone at this point I don't see why
you don't you don't face a serious
penalty representative Harry
gther thank you for taking my question
so is this bill supposed to be for the
dealer or is this bill directed towards
um people that do drugs together it's
anyone who distributes the
drug that's what who would apply to now
could it apply to two drug addicts who
are you know living in an apartment
together technically it can in those
scenarios I will say it's extremely
difficult to prove Who had who had what
first especially when the other person's
dead so although it could be prosecuted
that way that's not the likely scenario
but when you're dealing with someone
who's Distributing drugs and selling
them and that results in a death that's
what this is targeting I I also point
out that when it comes to law
enforcement getting
informance well someone facing 10 years
on their head they may uh that that's
how that's how this works from the
ground
up
representative
n thank you madam chair and thank you
for taking my question given that
fenel is ubiquitous um that it is
basically in everything and that we have
um thus far not past um testing and
analyzing comprehensive testing and anal
analyzing um capabilities how would you
um demonstrate that someone actually
knew what was in there and the amount
that was in what they were giving to
someone so demonstrating intent in any
way well it's the intent would apply to
them Distributing it now they're trying
to distribute a drug if you have what
you think is cocaine and it turns out to
be heroin the intent elements satisfied
because you're intending to distribute
said control substance that you believe
is a a drug that's a controlled
substance what the person's doing is
still illegal the fact that they didn't
know how much fentanyl is in there I
mean we do have testing strips we did
pass that law but with that being said
they're Distributing drugs we're talking
about someone who's dealing drugs that
are killing people and that's what we're
worried about here if someone says oh I
didn't I didn't know how much was in
there well it's it's a synthetic drug
and it's it's it includes the mixing
agent so the reason why people overdose
is that it's very difficult to tell how
much is in there based on its potency so
that's the problem and that's why we
want to really make a statement that you
need to stop dealing this because people
are dying because exactly what you said
they don't know what they're
doing can I just follow up really
quickly so is the intention
to save lives or is it to make a
statement well it's to save lives by
people who are doing this and it results
in the death of someone now they're in
jail that's one person engaging in
Behavior that's plaguing our society
that's now off the street so it's when
we say we make a statement what we're
trying to explain to the criminal
underworld and the people who are doing
things that they know will kill people
and people who are sick and I've lost
good friends to drug overdoses so I'm
not someone who's not and I'm sure a lot
of people can relate to that I mean one
of my best friends that I lived with her
five years in college died of fentanyl
all right he was an attorney just like
you know so no one no one's exempt here
but the person who gave him that
fentanyl I wish what they really did was
ask them to go to rehab or had them call
me but that's not what happened they
gave him a drug and now he's dead my
other friend who died his wake I
remember his wake was on was on the day
that his fiance's due date was for their
unborn child I wish same scenario I wish
that drug dealer rather than give him a
drug did something different and all
that person is going to get is a
distribution
charge I'm going to refrain from I think
they I think they belong in jail thank
you representative
Murray thank you madam chair um I don't
know off the top of my head so maybe you
can enlighten me if we're talking about
you know the intent not being death it's
like manslaughter right and I was just
wondering if there's a mandatory minimum
for manslaughter and is that 10 years I
don't believe I don't know the mandatory
up the top of my head it's um I don't
believe it's
10 no
mandatory
oh I'll take I'll take professor she at
his word who's not here on behalf of any
academic institution
right but
but with that being said this is a
little different than manslaughter
because I I would put this one step
above because you're
engaging in some in Behavior where you
really know that that there's a a
likelihood or at least a a possibility
of a harm happening and then when that
harm happens it's kind of hard to say
well I didn't mean for that to happen I
don't I think it's common knowledge even
amongst addicts about the high overdose
rat a lot of drug addicts will not do
drugs alone at least they try to avoid
doing that in case one of them
overdoses and that's why we passed the a
law um where if you're with someone who
overdoses and you bring them to the ER
that that person has immunity so we're
trying to save as many lives as possible
on every end of this but one of the ways
of doing that is to for the people who
are Distributing this there needs to be
penalties for it especially when they it
results in de I I certainly would be
shocked they are
surprised representative
Muse so as as I look at the statute a
judge currently has the ability to
actually sentence somebody who does this
to life in prison right
now
so what I would like to know is what
evidence you have that attacking a
mandatory minimum onto a crime that
already provides the potential for a
life sentence does uh in terms of
messaging I guess number one uh what
message aren't people getting by the
fact that the current statute has a life
sentence uh tacked onto it and the other
thing uh the other thing I'm curious
about also one of a Time representative
Muse please okay okay I represented
people facing a mandatory T to to life
trust me it weighs on them very much and
that's a that's a
very first of all that's that's a heavy
way for them to be carrying and it's
obviously a serious offense and it's one
of those instances where when that's out
there it really puts a stamp on what's
Happening when the it's a possibility
this a possibility there's a lot of
mitigating circumstances perhaps can
come up uh what we're saying is when
it's a mandatory sentence like this um
it's going to be a stiff penalty and is
it going to deter all this Behavior no
but it it's certainly I think a step in
the right
direction followup represent followup
yeah and and and I guess the other thing
that I'm curious about is is what is the
case that instituting a 10-year
mandatory minimum is actually going to
have any impact at all I mean have we
seen uh I know other states have been
approaching uh this issue in a similar
way have we started to see that those
states are actually getting better
results by doing this I'm not familiar
with how many other states have done it
because I think the first of all when it
comes to debts there's a lot of some
states are not doing their you know as
good of a job with Naran so some of the
numbers can be skewed in different
directions I think we've done our First
Responders have done an amazing job of
saving lives which is you know which is
unbelievably and they deserve a round of
applause but that also mitigates the
number down to where it doesn't look
like it's as much of a problem as it
still is so I think what we're trying to
deal with is the people who are
Distributing that drug uh this is how
you bring down these Enterprises where
they stop dealing the drugs that can
kill you from an overdose maybe they'll
stop lacing it into street level drugs
like LSD or or cannabis maybe they'll
stop doing that knowing that they're
going to face a mandatory
sentence that's what's happening is that
fentanyl is getting mixed into cocaine
it's getting mixed into heroin it's get
mix in other stuff and they're not even
telling the person that they're selling
it to that it's in there and then the
person's dying so as bad as it is to be
selling those other drugs mixing another
deadly drug in
there as a because it's less expensive
and it's basically the as a cutting
agent is is problematic and that's
what's causing a lot of these deaths so
we're trying to deter that behavior if
you don't think a mandatory sentence
deters the behavior I'm not sure why we
have the penalties in the first place
followup representative Muse we would
would you be okay if we came back to
that if it doesn't get answered because
we have I think four other people that
still have it's an immediate kind of a
thing if you don't mind okay real quick
please yeah
um um I'm I'm all said thank you I I
understand you don't prefer the
mandatory result but mandatory sentence
but if that if you don't think that's
the solution I are we interested in
hearing what what the solution is I
think it's a collective effort of
penalties strong mandatory sentences
also uh drug treatment mental health
treatment on the other side of it I
think it's a really you want to take
every angle possible and this is one of
one of the
angles so just before I continue to go
down my list I just want you guys to
know I do see your hands and I'm I'm
writing them down and before we go back
around the room I'm trying to get
everybody that had their hand up before
we go back for our second round uh
representative Stone thank you madam
chair and thank you for taking my
question senator in your experience do
we have drug dealers out there still
making uh rules of money off people's
pain and suffering by trafficking
narcotics that they particularly may not
indulge in
themselves that's what's happening some
some use it in themselves some don't but
but they not only is it C causing pain
and suffering it's causing people to
die thank
you representative celik thank you very
much um in uh and thank you particular
my question in line 12 U or 11 and 12 it
says that it it's if the death was not
um too remote in its occurrence as to
have just bearing on the person's
liability I was hoping you could clarify
what you what you mean by that or what
the bill means by that so my
understanding that's the ex that's the
existing law but I think sometimes when
someone takes a drug if they were to
let's say die the next day of let's say
like a heart attack it's much harder to
link it link that to it now could could
have contributed to their
death perhaps but that's really
something that a medical um expert would
have to make that
determination representative
bden um a few years ago I remember um it
was bipartisan legislation was passed
into law to um
forgive or or Overlook um the charge of
possession when someone makes a 911
called report an
overdose um but that only applies to the
charge possession and not with intent to
distribute and as I said that
was I think unanimously I think it
passed on consent and uh was a Voice
vote in the Senate and um so I'm curious
how a mandatory minimum on this sort of
penalty interplays with the
decision-making process when maybe
someone who supplied someone with a drug
that they're overdosing on is faced with
the option of leave and let them die or
call 911 and help them knowing that
maybe they would be spared the charge of
possession but could spend 10 years
behind bars what do you think that um
what decision do you think people would
make in that situation and how do you
think
it would play out as far as overdose
death rates in New
Hampshire oh I would have be speculating
on what people are thinking at the time
that when they gave someone a drug and
then watching the person die right in
front of them how they would handle it I
would hope that they would take that
person to the hospital or at least make
an anonymous call or do whatever use
that the other person's just do
something rather than leaving them there
to die could that happen I good friend
of mine sister that happened to
uh she overdosed the person with her did
nothing and she died in that person's
apartment you know I I I don't know how
those people can live with themselves
but that's what they're doing uh with
that being said again if that if someone
were to overdose it's very hard for law
enforcement and keep in mind the burden
of proof for a conviction Beyond A
Reasonable Doubt to De demonstrate who
gave what to who first if you have two
people using drugs you know in an
isolated area at for all you you for all
they know the person who overdose is the
one who supplied the drug they don't
know that absent a confession so it's
unusual for that to happen but they
would have immunity I think just to the
POS potential of the possession charge I
shouldn't say immunity any I I believe
it's I'm going top of my head but any
evidence they get during that process
where they reported it the overdose have
brought them to the hospital that would
be um they couldn't use any of that
evidence
obtained
follow thank you
um in my experience and I think it's
limited
um I'm not seeing a lot of people in New
Hampshire um with a substance abuse
issue that also have a
JD um so if they don't know about burden
of proof they haven't been educated in
that they don't know the exact wording
of the law is there a possibility that
hearing about a mandatory minimum would
adversely impact the likelihood that
someone would call 911 potentially
resulting in unsolved um you know
situations where there's I remember
hearing from a republican um a
republican lawmaker who was an EMT about
finding um you know bodies in the snow
bank outside of the ER and hearing from
police officers about getting a call to
a location for an overdose and finding a
dead body and driver's license in the
scene of being cleaned and so like
looking back on those situations that
occurred that resulted in creating the
immunity law that we have in
place I guess I'm just
wondering is it possible that the
unforeseen consequence of this
legislation as proposed would cause more
overdose deaths as opposed to reversed
overdoses and would it cause more
overdose deaths with no evidence at the
scene instead of someone calling 911 one
getting someone help and being present
and cooperating with
police I would have no way of answering
that accurately because I have no
nothing to no study or information to
base that on I would certainly hope not
because that's clearly not the intent of
the bill is to cause more deaths I I I
always lean back on if there's no one
selling fentanyl no one's going to
overdose from It ultimately I understand
you got to treat people who are addicted
you got deal with the mental health side
of things there's a lot of pieces here
but if no one sold it and no one
distributed it that solves your fentanyl
problem that's where it all starts so I
think we got to be mindful of that and
for the people that are going to be
Distributing it I think that we got to
keep make this a mandatory sentence do
people will people not report
it I'm not
sure representative
Newman I have just a question on on the
wording of the bill because I've heard
testimony about dealers selling we've
got to stop that kind of thing and it
looks like in the bill we've made two
changes that are that kind of make it
man make it be what it is and it change
May to shall so there used to be
judicial
discretion on and the judge was was able
to do have judicial discretion
and then it it says and maybe you can
explain this to me because I'm not sure
I understand the phrase correctly
strictly liable so does that mean that
they don't have to be selling it they
could just be giving
sharing the the uh the drug with someone
and then someone dies and then they are
subject to this mandatory minimum so
distri thank you for the question
distribution does not necessarily
require an exchange of consideration so
if you want to just hand it to people as
a gift that's that's a form of
distribution which can just as likely
kill someone as the person selling
it
followup followup okay
so is is there something in here that
says distribution is is required I all I
see is strictly liable for a death well
I'm using the the term distribution but
it says manufact existing laws
manufacturer sells or
dispenses so it's talking about when
what happens when you that I'm just kind
of summing up in a general term is
distribution yeah I didn't see that but
it all it's all connected so when
manufacturers it only for someone to
sell it only for someone to then
dispense it that that's what's happening
thank
you representative her G are you good um
yes and no so thank you for taking my
question
um so if this bill was to pass um would
you agree that this bill takes away the
discretion of the judicial of the
judges uh when it comes to applying the
mandatory sentence it does limit the
discretion because there obviously it's
a mandatory sentence but the judge would
have the discretion to sentence that
person beyond what the mandatory is up
to a life
sentence why do you say
that so someone who's convicted under
this yeah it's a mandatory 10 up to a
life they the judge could sentence them
to say 15 years or 12 years you know all
right that that would be within a
judge's discretion but not less sorry
but not less than correct hold on a
minute correct okay thank you
representative Reed thank you madam
chairman this is a little bit off but
relevant nonetheless we're losing a lot
of lives def fent all overdoses do you
think shutting down the Border would cut
off the supply as well and perhaps
that's something that we should address
thank you I wish we could address that
at the state level I I think a lot of
the the illegal fentanyl comes into this
country it's coming in through the
southern border there's also fentanyl
coming in through the northern border uh
would that stop this problem
instantaneously it it would certainly
help because you get rid of the
supply well that's a big part of it if
there's no Supply you know supply and
demand right
Senator with
this we have a lot of bills that have to
do with fentanyl we're hearing it
Non-Stop and we keep on using or hearing
the term of harm reduction do you think
this would be a tool along with the harm
reduction if the people are not able or
at least know that there's going to be a
serious consequence to destroying
families destroying communities the
state the country as a whole absolutely
the worst harm you can cause is death I
that literally killing someone is the
worst thing you can do and when you if
the people who are causing the death of
other people are no longer um able to do
that at least they're they're
incarcerated I think that that's that
will ultimately lead to harm reduction
because if they sell it to me they'll
sell it to
you representative
Pratt
hello old friend old friend here to Yes
uh could this be called a benefit versus
risk
Bill where a drug dealer is willing to
risk another person's life to make a
profit well I think the drug dealers are
doing that now so they're already doing
that and this is trying to stop and they
I think that they're aware that what
they're doing could cause the death of
someone and they may sell someone drugs
and then you know knowing that that
person may share with you know amongst
their their other you know friends or
whatever and they're doing it anyway so
yeah just follow up follow up um so this
is basically trying to modify a deal as
Reckless Behavior in the results of a
death of another person I would call it
intentional Behavior but
yes representative nman do you have a
followup yes I just have a followup to
on once I found the word cell I went
back and read again and if you look on
line
four it says all that above and then it
says or is strictly liable for a death
so does that still include the sale when
it says or or or do I have to rely
strictly on the on the definition of
strictly liable but thank you for the qu
question I think what you're asking me
is the existing law but when you say
you're strictly liable whether
regardless of which one you did it if
you're handing it out you're giving it
out you're selling it you're trading it
you know what you know for a sandwich
whatever it is you're doing what
whatever it is you're doing if you're
the one that's putting it out there into
Commerce that's includes manufacturing
whatever it is you're doing uh yes you
are liable whether you intended to kill
someone or not they're saying based on
the fact that you did something that
caused the death of someone where it it
is clearly should be on the person's
radar be shocked to find a single person
um that's an adult that would actually
believe that fentanyl isn't killing
people or could not kill someone thank
you and if you know how small of amount
of fentanyl it is to kill someone yes I
do we'll find that on the on the next
bill two two milligrams I
believe Senator I I think that we
stirred this soup enough we're going to
go ahead and let you off the hook now
thank you very much thank you madam
chair Mr
Summers
good
afterno okay good afternoon my name is
Grace Summers I'm the executive director
of the addiction recovery Coalition of
New Hampshire and
Milford I thank Vice chair rhods and The
Honorable committee honorable members of
this committee for time to speak and
testify on this legislation Arc is a
community Recovery Center that treats
that treats substance use disorder at a
community level by providing a central
location for access to local support
systems and peer peer support services
our personal experiences with subance
use disorder Drive our passion and
urgency in addressing this epidemic
using a peer-to-peer based approach with
so many Pathways to Recovery available
we guide individuals in finding the
pathway that feels most most aligned
with their values and needs prior to
this role I co-founded an inhome
addiction treatment company aware
Recovery Care and I'm also the former
president of Anthem Blue Cross Blue
Shield New Hampshire is currently
grapping grappling with a severe
addiction crisis largely fueled by the
widespread availability of opioids such
as Fentanyl and its
analoges however the proposed
legislation both SB 414 and 4 15 if
enacted would inflict further harm upon
those already suffering the most from
this epidemic individuals struggling
with opioid addiction and other subance
use disorders it would lead to the
incarceration of citizens who do not
pose a threat to our state but are
instead in dire need of support and
treatment for their subance use
disorders rather than spending
approximately
$68,000 per citizen per year to
incarcerate the individuals I question
why we wouldn't allocate these tax
dollars toward evidence-based prevention
treatment harm reduction and Recovery
initiatives s SP 414 would inadvertently
contribute to an increase in overdoses
and related fatalities individuals
associated with those using these
substances will naturally hesitate to be
present during drug drug consumption if
they fear legal repercussions
administering the lock Zone brand named
Nan is impossible while the user is
unconscious further heightening the risk
of fatal
overdoses it's instructive to note that
New Hampshire has made significant
strides and reducing its overdose death
rate which has declined to
13.3 for 1,000 citizens in
2021 after being the third worst state
in the United States for overdose deaths
in
2016 I do not believe the intent of this
legislation is to fill our jails and
prisons with some of the most vulnerable
citizens yet if these bills are passed
that is precisely what will happen
instead I urge this committee to Target
the dealers and suppliers responsible
for trafficking illegal
narcotics specifically I propose
increasing the Quant
of fentanyl specified incate Bill 414 to
at least 28 gr it should be noted that
many
users of fentanyl average four to five
grams per
day I also would implore the committee
to look at
eliminating mandatory minimum s
sentences without judicial
discretion we must focus on holding
those primarily responsible for the
addiction epidemic
accountable without needlessly
increasing the rate of incarceration for
those desperate in need of assistance
it's crucial to recall the failure of
mandatory minimum sentencing laws for
drug possession which began during the
crack cocaine epidemic of the
1980s the incarceration rate in the US
surged from 100 per 100,000 in
1972 to 760 for 100,000 in 2008 with
minimal impact on patient
safety I implore the legislature to take
prompt action to amend the quantity of
Fentanyl and its analoges and
sp415 and to abolish mandatory minimum
sentencing let us also prioritize
allocating funds to support
evidence-based and effective addiction
treatment which has been proven to
mitigate the impact of addiction and
enhance Community safety thank you
representative n thank you madam chair
and thank you for taking my question um
I really want to kind of drill down a
little bit on what we're talking about
when we say dealers I think people um
are referring to to uh something beyond
the scope of what this would uh actually
entail so for example you were saying
the average user I think you said 46
milligrams but I didn't write it down
right away so right I said the average
some average users some users Aver
average 45 Mig of fentanyl per day yes
and so my My ultimate question is um in
your experience working with people who
are uh struggling with substance use um
is it common for someone who is in the
midst of that um to uh to sell to
support their own
habit um I mean anecdotally um that
happens on occasion but typically the
folks that we work with our participants
are the are the users they're not
selling the drug thank
you representative Reed thank you madam
chairman what
how what um do most substance use misus
people how do they support their habit
how do most of these people afford their
their addiction thank you yeah I think
it would be speculation for me to say
anything to ative certainly um some
people are employed um some people um
have their own financial means to do so
um and it varies widely from Individual
to
individual representative
Pratt uh thank you for coming today I'm
asking a question about the number you
through our a minute ago about the 13
per thousand what was that number the um
you talking about the incarceration rate
no I think you were talking about the
drug overdose rate has dropped down 13
out of a thousand which is an acceptable
rate I said the uh drug overd the drug
overdose rate per 1,000 has dropped to
32.3 individuals as of
2021 the number was much higher in 2016
when New Hampshire had the third worst
weight third worst um overdose rate of
deaths in the United States if you
divide
a population of 1.3 million people by a
thousand that would be like over
18,000 overdoses a
year uh 30 to do the quick quick math
now would be
um three I don't have to have an exact
number I just we're talking thousands or
hundreds of thousands of overdoses is
that acceptable level yeah I I can go
back and look at the attribution but um
those are the facts as
we gathered them thank you sure
representative Stone thank you madam
chair and thank you for taking my
question in your experience do a lot of
these individuals that are street level
users do they commit other crimes to
finance their
habit um again where I come from in
Milford we don't see um actually much
crime associated with that that might
occur in other areas but um we're not uh
we don't see a lot of it does it does it
happen for sure it does thank you
representative sik thank you and thank
you for taking my question I'm wondering
do you see any potential to this to
being for harm reduction or do you think
that those efforts are better spent
elsewhere from this legislation for harm
reduction um I don't see this
legislation as engendering harm
reduction really at all I think there's
other efforts that would be much better
suited for harm
reduction see no more questions thank
you very much thank you very
much Miss
Anderson hello my name is Lucy Anderson
thank you for allowing me the time to
speak as a community member person in
recovery from substance use disorder and
employee of SOS recovery Community
organization I appreciate the
opportunity to submit testimony and
opposition to both Bill 414 and
4:15 3 years ago to the week my best
friend died of an overdose he was smart
and kind and resilient and a valuable
member of his community I tell you this
because I want you all to know how
intimately aware I am of the impact
drugs have on our communities overdose
deaths have had an incredible toll on
community Statewide and I know we share
a common goal of public health and
safety unfortunately the proposed
legislation would not make our
communities safer but rather Target
those most in need of support and
evidence-based Services while the goal
of mandatory minimum sentences and
harsher penalties for death resulting
may be intended to Target large scale
dealers that is not what will happen if
this legislation is passed instead it
would result in the incarceration of
individuals working tremendously hard to
battle substance use disorder create
Better Lives for themselves and their
loved ones and in many cases simply
survive under the unfair circumstances
Society has created for them the
incarceration of such neighbors would
cost New Hampshire taxpayers enormous
amounts of money which could better be
spent funding evidence-based substance
use prevention recovery and harm
reduction Services the decision to spend
taxpayer money on incarc ation rather
than quality and accessible treatment
and harm reduction supports would be an
error as it would not build up
communities but rather ravage them
individual punishment does not serve as
an effective solution for this communal
and societal problem people who use
drugs and or are in recovery constitute
some of our state's most vulnerable and
resilient members and it is our duty to
approach this issue with evidence-based
Solutions I personally know people who
have been impacted by mandatory minimum
sentencing laws and I can assure you
that they were not cartel leaders I also
know people who had Mand had mandatory
minimum sentencing laws been in place
would currently be incarcerated instead
of given the opportunity to become
valuable community members I will never
forget sitting with my dearest friend as
she was tried for fentanyl possession do
the the fact that no mandatory minimum
existed the judge assigned to her case
was able to determine that she was not a
threat to safety but rather a victim
herself today instead of being
incarcerated she is in school of
pursuing her bachelor's degree and
working as a champion for substance use
disorder recovery in her Ral Community
her story does not have to be
unique I think it is somewhat absurd to
sit in this room with the assumption
that we are the people who know best how
to address this issue it is people who
use drugs that are on the front lines it
is people who use drugs that don't want
their loved ones to Die the most it is
people who use drugs who are most
infrequently who are most frequently
administering the lock Zone otherwise
known as our can for these reasons I
urge you to oppose both bills 414 and
415 thank
you representative Su thank you so much
for people who might be watching or
elsewhere can you just explain what SOS
recovery is I I'm familiar with it but
some people might not be familiar with
that acronym absolutely so SOS recovery
Community organization is a recovery
Community organization that offers peer
support in a variety of services so we
offer harm reduction support such as
providing safe use supplies and we offer
support navigating the criminal justice
system uh and it really is everything on
a day-to-day I can help someone get an
ID one minute help them get on a shelter
list another minute and provide safe use
supplies the next minute so I really
believe that the funding of
evidence-based harm reduction Solutions
such as those SOS recovery Community
organizations provide would be a better
use of our
funding Mr
Barry
good afternoon Madam chair honorable
members of the committee my name is Jake
Barry I'm the vice president of policy
at new Futures as many of you know new
Futures is nonpartisan nonprofit Health
policy and advocacy organization we've
been working for more than 25 years to
address alcohol and substance use issues
in our state I don't want to repeat too
much of what's been said this afternoon
but I do want to stress new Future's
strong opposition both to this bill sb14
414 and the next bill has be 415 simply
put the data shows that mandatory
minimums don't work they don't deter
individuals from using or selling drugs
they don't save lives reduce costs or or
reduce human suffering to the contrary
mandatory minimums often lead to
increased incarcerate increased rates of
incarceration and greater racial
disparities within our Criminal Justice
System here in New Hampshire rather than
focusing on criminal penalties we have
worked hard to recognize substance use
disorder for what it is a chronic
relapsing condition of the brain that
needs to be treated not one that needs
to be punished uh we have invested to
expand our substance use treatment
Network we have we have prioritized harm
reduction principles and systems we have
worked to establish drug courts to try
and all for the sake of trying to keep
people out of the Criminal Justice
System uh data seems to show that this
is working as we noted earlier uh the
number of Overdose tests recorded in
2023 was at
422 while that number is far too high it
is down 50 from the year prior and
looking nationally as was ref referenced
earlier our fatal overdose rate uh which
was as high as third in the country back
in 2016 uh fell to 22nd in 2021 the most
recent data
available in addition to incarcerating
individuals and limiting their access to
treatment we fear that these bills will
punish taxpayers and stretch the budgets
of our prisons and jails and our
counties which are already stretch to
their
limits uh a recent report from the
Council of state governments shows that
it costs our counties and average 100 of
$185 to house a single inmate for a
single day extend that over the 3 and2
year minimum sentence required under
sb45 and that jumps to
$236,300
75,200 much of which will fall on the
backs of taxpayers imagine if we just
put a fraction of that money towards
substance use treatment and Recovery uh
systems and programs for these people in
need it would certainly go a long way to
help help increase access to treatment
and help individuals achieve long-term
recovery and helping our state finally
bring an end to this addiction crisis
for these reasons we urge you to oppose
both SP 414 and 415 and vote them itl uh
thank you and I'm happy to take
questions of Stone thank you madam chair
and thank you for taking my question so
in your opinion do you feel that the
individual that results in the death of
another human being should basically be
giving a
warning I no no certainly not I think
that there are many you know there there
are many tools within our criminal
justice system to address this now I I
think that I would say that it's a you
know this is a complicated question I
think that when you're talking about
substance use disorder you're talking
about addiction distribution of drug you
know many people um I think we all have
in our minds the idea of these drug
cartels that are coming in and selling
in large quantities and targeting people
I think that uh you know when it comes
to distribution of drugs it's not always
that easy it's not that clear-cut I
think that this bill the way it's
written would broadly apply to people
who again are not selling in huge
quantities but are are using themselves
or sharing with Friends uh and you know
they they far too many people are dying
on behalf of that but some of the people
who are connected to this are
experiencing again addiction themselves
and I think that they uh these are
things that need to be treated for their
sake for the sake of their families and
for the sake of our entire State I think
that U you know again I think treatment
is um the
priority could you give me your
definition of what a street level dealer
is oh there are others um there are
others in the room who could answer that
much better than I do I would certainly
um defer to Professor Sher or others who
who work more closely with it than me
but I think that um again in in our view
I think that many of us picture have a
certain picture in our mind of what a
street level dealer is but I think that
they uh it's much harder to Define than
that and applies to many people well
thank you for your response thank you
thank
you Mr
Burns
good afternoon my name is John Burns and
thank you all for being here and giving
me the opportunity to speak I am the
executive director for SOS recovery
Community
organization we have peer-based recovery
centers in Dover Rochester Hampton um we
also off we also provide a Workforce
Development restaurant social Enterprise
restaurant in summersworth we employ
about 27
individuals um and I a person in the
long-term recovery with experience with
drug use and homelessness I have a
daughter who is in recovery and am a
family member and I am standing here in
opposition to both um 414 and 415 um I
think these are harmful bills I think
it's important to look at the human
element behind what these policies
address and it's stunning to me that we
are talking about mandatory minimums
because we've already been down this
road we did this in the 80s it it failed
miserably there's a plethora of of data
Nationwide data that showed that all it
did was increase overdose death rates
not decrease them there was no evidence
to show that it helped people stop using
drugs what it what there is evidence to
show is that it put more people in
prison and that's it and and did so with
wide disparities because we know that
when we look at our drug policies in
this country that there's a disparity
for communities of color and those
impacted by poverty and so this
increases those disparities because it
is the people who are the most
marginalized and the most vulnerable
that tend to be um affected by mandatory
minimums it takes the discretion away
from judges and it gives them to the
prosecutor which in turn results in um
unfair like if if we're appointing
judges and we're confirming them and we
trust that they're neutral why do we
want to take their Authority away and
hand that to the prosecution and and un
unbalance um the sentences that already
exist and I also think when we look at
people who use drugs we work we provide
harm reduction supplies and services at
all of our recovery centers um we do
Outreach with our homeless
communities you know when we look at
three and a half years for five
grams the basically what you're
targeting there is the individual who
has the car and the license to go pick
up their substances and often times that
money is pulled with three or four of
their peers that they're using with and
now they're looking at a three and a
half year prison sentence cuz they had
the car they had the transportation It's
Not Unusual on a day-to-day basis for me
to work with individuals with with daily
use of two to three grams upwards of
five grams sometimes so five grams could
be what somebody uses in a day and yet
here we are looking at a 3 and a half
year prison sentence what they do need
is they have a health care issue here we
have a chronic health issue that needs
treatment it needs recovery supports it
does not need more prison time all the
prison time is going to do is is create
more barriers it removes access to them
receiving any sort of help and when
they're released they now have a myriad
more be more of a myriad of more
barriers to getting well and increases
and there's evidence to show that that
will that for those incarcerated it is
only going to increase recidivism
because what they're going to learn ins
out of a prison is not going to help
them on the outside when they get out so
you know I I these are troubling um
because I look at the work we do and at
every turn in order to to be funded we
have to prove that what we're doing is
evidence-based and we do and nothing we
do that's funded isn't evident
evidence-based but yet we move forward
policies like this and say we will
support them with evidence that says
they're harmful and there's no evidence
that can be provided that's going to
show this is going to reduce overdose
deaths there's no evidence that this is
going to reduce drug use deterrence like
this is not a deterrent and there's no
evidence that shows it is and yet we
keep pounding our fists on the table
saying well maybe if we just increase
the penalties people will listen and
they'll stop you know the the I
constantly see people that I know facing
death resulting people that I've worked
with in our recovery centers trust me if
I know them they're not connected to
cartels these are street level kids and
these are people who are sharing their
drugs with their friends there you don't
even have to sell to get a death
resulting all you have to do is go buy a
bag and share it with two or three of
your friends and you are now guilty of
death resulting if one of them dies and
to the point that was made about the
immunity laws in New Hampshire we do
Nock Zone training on the streets in in
our Outreach on a regular basis when we
tell them encourage them we part of our
training is encourage them to call 911
and regularly we hear from participants
I'm not calling 911 not with those death
resulting laws if I'm using with
somebody there's no way I'm calling 911
and so we encourage them to call anyways
and run when they hear the siren if if
nothing else just so that that person
gets Medical Care um and we know these
are the people that are reversing
overdoses way more people are overdose
deaths are reversed with public
administration of Noone by people who
use drugs than by First Responders and
it's terrifying to me that they're
scared to call um and that that tends to
increase overdose deaths rather than
help it when we put laws like these in
place so I I thank you all for listening
and hearing our testimony and I hope you
will um oppose both of these pieces of
legislation thank
you thank you Mr Burns is there any
questions representative n thank you
madam chair and thank you for taking my
question um I think a lot of the framing
is around um um harsher penalties being
more of a deterrent so my my question is
in your experience working with so many
people not uh not the least of which is
yourself and and your daughter um is are
fear stress and shame conducive to
recovery are they do um does that
increase your potential for Recovery or
uh decrease it no in my opinion well the
definition of a substance use disorder
is problematic or chaotic use regardless
of
consequences so our aren't worried about
consequences when we have a substance
use disorder it's we're focused on not
getting sick generally speaking at least
that was my experience I didn't I wasn't
I figured I wouldn't get arrested for
anything I did um and my cat use didn't
lead to fear of being arrested uh than
run if I saw police near me so thank
you representative
Balden thank you um I know that you been
working as an advocate um since
before this legislature passed into law
the immunity um when you're reporting an
overdose how could you speak in more
detail to how the passage of that
affected overdose death rates and how
you believe a mandatory minimum would
affect the rate of death yeah I don't
know how much the mandat minimum is
going to affect it um I I can't help it
I know that what I do know is that prior
to that immunity law being
passed there was widespread what we
would call dumping of of people at
hospital room entries where you would
literally like it was like a tuck and
roll people would just drive by the
emergency room open a door and push
people out that it overdosed because
they were so afraid of getting arrested
and they still wanted them to get help
but they were not in a position where
they were they were too scared of of an
arrest at that at at that moment um I
remember people pulling up to our
recovery centers out front with somebody
overdosing in their car that's happened
multiple times prior to the immunity law
um where they would come and they'd run
in the door like I know you guys have no
lockone right and we'd go out and help
them reverse that overdose so um and and
what I have seen is as the Attorney
General's office Focus their
prosecutions around death resulting we
have seen that it has had a substantial
impact on
that immunity law and watering it down
to the point that people don't take it
that seriously so mandatory minimums is
only going to increase I think that
attitude and that fear that what's like
this immunity doesn't mean
anything thank you very much thank
you Mr
Lin
good afternoon my name is Ted lothstein
thank you for hearing me I am here on
behalf of the New Hampshire Association
of criminal offense lawyers I'm um been
a criminal offense lawyer here in New
Hampshire for 29 years and a member of
that Organization for almost that entire
time and the first thing I want to say
is I understand where the anger that
lies behind a
like this comes from you know I've
raised my wife and I have raised our
children to quazi adulthood here in
conquer over the last 20 year 22
years and um and elsewhere in New
Hampshire and um we've traveled around
the country and seen the ravages of
drugs in cities and here in New
Hampshire and it's really hard and I see
it in my job every
day um I understand the sense that you
know we got to do something big we have
to make a statement but this is the
wrong approach it's the wrong approach
because it just transfers discretion I
mean that these types of bills the
people who support mandatory minimums
which we used to have in New Hampshire
and realize were wrong and mostly got
rid of but people who support them want
to take away discretion from a judge but
all they're doing is giving the same
discretion more to the prosecutor who
decides what charge to bring in the
first place um in the Senate hearing a
state police sergeant I believe
testified very correctly by the way that
that um death result in cases are
difficult to prove they are very
difficult to prove prosecutors tend to
prefer loow hanging fruit things that
are easier to prove someone in this in
this room asked a question you know what
are we talking about here are we talking
about BigTime drug dealers or are we
talking about people who do drugs
together and the senator correctly
stated that our definition of dispan
distribute just means to give it to
somebody else it doesn't matter if it's
people using together and and um I think
that the other speakers we just heard
would agree drug using is a very
communal activity a very shared activity
just like drinking alcohol people obtain
it together share it with each other and
use it together and so which case will
be the first to prosecute is the easiest
and that's simple um two people who are
um drug addicted friends or
acquaintances um you one of them gets
the drugs using shared money they do it
together and someone um overdoses at
that point what would a good person do a
good person at that point obviously will
call for help and try to save their
friend's life what would a bad person do
run because as the state police sergeant
said it's very hard to prove these
cases um when the person stays helps and
tells the police what happens it's the
good person who will get the 10-year
mandatory minimum not the bad person who
flees because they're somehow aware of
this law and don't want to get a 10-year
mandatory minimum so it goes after it
ends up being applied to the wrong
people again the prosecutor decides are
we just going to charge a person with
possession are we going to charge them
with distribution or are we going to
charge them with death resulting that is
100% a decision made by a prosecutor
often right at of law school often
between 25 and 30 years old often who
has not been married raised children and
gone you know had all the life
experiences and heartache we have over a
longer period of Our Lives they don't
have the life experiences and the wisdom
of Judges they're also making decisions
that are not accountable when a judge
makes a decision she has to say it out
loud or write it down and you can take
to a higher Court when prosecutors make
a decision who to go after with the
death with the mandatory minimum um they
they make their decisions in private
without having to State their reasons
and and almost completely
unreviewable um so moving the discretion
from judges who can sentence all the way
up to life in prison but don't have a
floor to prosecutors to decide which
people should get 10 years here's what
that that will lead to one is it will
lead to the the the great the greatest
injustices you know because again it's
much harder to prove it with a
sophisticated person who who who be who
conceals their tracks than against a
vulnerable street level person who did
drugs with their friend and then tried
to save their friend's life
unsuccessfully um and so the most
vulnerable people will be the ones
targeted for the mandatory minimums but
the other problem with mandatory
minimums is that mandatory minimums
cause innocent people to go to prison
and that really applies here because the
people who are innocent in these
scenarios They're Not Innocent of all
wrongdoing they they're using drugs
maybe they're sharing drugs maybe
they're selling drugs but again as the
state police sergeant said it's very
hard to figure out and to prove who
actually supplied the drugs that killed
the person because addicts have so many
different sources and so much and and
drugs are just passed around um and so
what you know what you end up with is
that a person who dispensed gave or sold
drugs that didn't kill the deceased is
prosecuted for death resulting and is
they're told by their lawyer we can take
it to trial but if he lose there's a
10-year mandatory minimum and
prosecutors use that as a cudgle to get
the person to agree to five six seven
years in prison 2 three four years in
prison the same person that for the the
same crime would have gotten um maybe a
diversion program maybe a house of
correction sentence maybe their first
felony conviction but not
prison um and so it's a it's a a
powerful tool that's too easy to abuse
mandatory minimums because it forces
people into decision- making like well
even though I'm innocent if there's a
20% chance I'll be convicted after trial
and I'm being offered one year in prison
and I'll do 10 if I'm wrongfully
convicted I guess I'll just say that I'm
the one who caused the
death
so what happens at that point is
prosecutors then say okay you've agreed
to app plea bargain will remove the
death resulting part so you don't have
to face the 10-year mandatory minimum
and you will sign up for whatever prison
sentence you signed up for under that
duress the New Hampshire Association of
criminal offense lawyers opposes both um
415 and four and Senate Bill 415 but my
comments would be exactly the same and
um I read the sheet that's going to be
distributed by Devon chaffy the ACLU and
the Hampshire Association criminal
defense lawyers agrees with all those
points and that's why I haven't repeated
them here
today thank you the committee have any
questions
representative thank you um Mr chair um
and thank you for taking my question I'm
I'm curious um so I live in Durham we
have the university so if we have Joe
college student who has come to school
with what they believe is a bottle of
Aderall that they've picked up from a
friend um and they say to their study
group okay we all need a lot more energy
and more focused I've got this Aderall
we could just share it so they
distributed except that they didn't test
it because they just thought it was
Aderall and it turns out that it's not
just Aderall and one of their peers dies
would that based on your interpretation
of this law would that person then be
subject to the 10-year mandatory minimum
if if it was leased with one of these
um category drugs yes and I think the
senator correctly answered that question
representative Cel that is because it's
a strict liability crime all they have
to prove is the person knew they were
distrib dispensing a controlled drug
they don't have to know which controlled
drug it was they don't have to know is
ventanal it's a very pertinent question
because a lot of opiate drugs are sold
in the street now have fentanyl instead
of what the person expects there to be
they're it's awful they're now sold in
pill form so that you know the pill
resembles like a perco set but you don't
know is it opiates in there or is it
something else or is it fentanyl so
absolutely and I think the college
setting is the best way to understand
this because most of us have been to
college at least for a while and um in
that setting you know if there's several
people in a room and there's a case of
beer we all know that not not every
Everybody didn't go out and buy one beer
each somebody pulled money or somebody
just went out and bought a case of beer
that person is the person dispensing the
beer just like in your question whoever
brought in the drug that they thought
was I can't remember what drug you said
but they thought was not venl that
person is the one dispensing thank
you any other questions from committee
members representative B
I suppose on that in that vein could
there be
complications I guess I'm foreseeing
consequences with this legislation in
situations where someone might be caring
for an elderly person or someone
who
um does the I guess does the bill
clarify the difference between elicit
and prescription
overdoses um because I know that people
with cancer take Fentanyl and people
post surgery take
oxycoton I think well the I mean the
definition of a controlled drug is not
prescribed so and I think most of that
if you're saying that the fentanyl was
prescribed I think that would take it
out of the the issue we're talking
about representative
Newman thank thank you for taking my
question um the bill is it's written and
I'll just take a little bit of it here
that says shall be sentenced to the
mandatory minimum sentences shall shall
be sentenced to not less than 10 years
of imprisonment does that leave room in
there for a plea bargain before a trial
or does that wording mean that they
would have to go through a trial and
then be sentenced and then the mandatory
minimum would apply or or could or does
the men I guess my bottom line question
does the mandatory minimum apply if they
were offered a plead bargain of some
nature maybe they'd have to go to a
lesser penalty right that's what I was
trying to say is that that if the start
the charge to begin with is a death
resulting charge the prosor can always
offer a plea bargain to just
distribution of the drug possession of
the drug you know some reckless conduct
as a felony some other offense and so
there's ways to get out of the 10 years
and what this these bills do is it just
gives that power to a 28-year-old
prosecutor who's been at a law school
for 3 years instead of giving it to a
judge who's been vetted by the executive
councel appointed by a governor and um
and subject to a pellet
review thank
you thank you thank
you Devin chy
come on
down thank you honorable members of the
committee um for the record my name is
Devon chaffy I'm the executive director
of the ACLU of New Hampshire and I am
here today to testify an opposition to
HB
414 um I want to start by just putting
um these bills in context right today
you're going to hear three bills that
create mandatory minimums for drug
related crimes um I want to just hearken
back to um a point that was made by a
previous speaker that recently New
Hampshire has very much moved away from
all mandatory minimums across the board
in its criminal code um and in fact in
I've been advocating at the state house
for a little over a decade and there
have been very few times when I have
seen proposals to introduce new
mandatory minimums most of the bills I
have seen over the years have all been
pulling back on mandatory minimums
sentences in our laws um and there is so
this this these bills together represent
a significant shift and would represent
a significant shift in how uh New
Hampshire goes about administering
criminal justice in our system and there
are many reasons I believe why New
Hampshire has chosen not to go um
forward with across the board like um
many mandatory minimums especially in
the uh drug context and I do want to
highlight that that support for reducing
mandatory minimums has historically come
from both sides of the aisle um and I
would never speak for another
organization but I do think it's worth
noting here today that both the New
Hampshire Liberty Alliance and the
Americans for Prosperity both opposed
these bills in the Senate so these are
two fairly conservative traditionally
considered conservative organiz ations
who opposed these bills in the Senate
because of the mandatory minimums and
the reason why there's historically been
this opposition to mandatory minimums is
New Hampshire as I think fourfold one
they are expensive two they are
uneffective three they're sort of a oniz
fits-all form of justice that don't take
into account the particulars of a given
case and finally they transfer judicial
discretion away from the Judiciary and
two prosecutors as was described earlier
now I'm going to dig more into some of
these points um and when I testify on HB
415 in a moment but for right now I
really want to focus on the particularly
egregious aspects of HB 415 which is of
course creating uh 10-year mandatory
minimum for death resulting which as has
been discussed is a strict liability
crime you don't have to know what you
are uh pass passing to another
individual in order to be subject to
this mandatory minimum and it's a crime
of essentially passing drugs to someone
else who then dies of an
overdose and I know that the senator in
presenting this bill says that well he
thinks it's unlikely that the folks that
are going to be that are prosecuted
under this law are are the the friends
or the loved ones of the person who
eventually dies but I want to tell you
that there has been a national
analysis of the prosecution under death
resulting laws across this nation and
the conclusion has been that it is not
drug dealers that are primarily
prosecuted and when you think about it
that shouldn't be surprising because
drug dealers don't stick around long
enough to get picked up by the cops and
Associated by a death instead what we
see here and this is again there's been
um studies of these
prosecutions that show this in many of
these deaths we're talking about
individuals who are friends and families
of the deceased often times themselves
struggling with the drug use disorder
and I really encourage you there's been
a podcast on this in New Hampshire cases
specifically and to read some of the
bios of these cases because it is
heart-wrenching when you read these
cases we're talking about friends who go
to jail for over a decade because they
were using together cuz they were afraid
to use alone right there are people a
husband whose wife wife uh bought heroin
and then asked her husband to please
inject her with that heroin and her
husband was prosecuted under these laws
um a wife whose husband asked her for
some some prescribed liquid methadone to
help him fall asleep who then passed in
his sleep um to and the wife you know
woke up and and tragically her husband
had passed so these cases I would I
would put before you are the definition
of why judicial discretion is so
important to make sure that the
punishments that are meted out under our
Criminal Justice System actually line up
with our understanding of what is
just moreover and this I cannot
emphasize enough there has been a lot of
studies that demonstrate very clearly
that death resulting laws and mandatory
minimum sentences do not reduce opioid
deaths they do not reduce drug use and
they do not reduce crime and I've
extensively cited studies and I'll pass
out my written testimony in a moment and
you can look at those citations um but
if you look at a particularly um a a
particular study of drug induced
homicide practices in the jurisdictions
of New Jersey Tennessee North Carolina
Illinois Louisiana in New York it
demonstrates clearly that despite
dramatic growths in the drug induced
homicide prosecutions death resulting
prosecutions all jurisdictions experienc
significant increases in over those
deaths in that same year what has worked
instead in New Hampshire and this was
discussed before were the laws that you
all have passed that have actually
allowed greater availability of noo Zone
that has resulted in the decline in
overdose
deaths and I just want to end my remarks
um because I want you to know that I the
the the pain caused by overdo deaths are
not the pain caused is not lost on me
those deaths are unspeakably tragic and
they cause unimaginable pain and anguish
and I can relate to that in 2020 I lost
um my cousin to an overdose somebody I
was very close with um and I grieved
with his mom and dad and with my family
and so I understand just the sliver of
the pain that is caused by these deaths
in our community and and I have to say
that personally when I think about my
cousin would I wish for a friend or a
girlfriend or a co- user even of my
cousins to be jailed for 10 years as
retribution for his passing or is what I
really wish that he wouldn't have been
using a loan that somebody had been
there with him who had Naran and could
have saved his life and I have to say
that for me the answer is clear and for
that reason I respectfully ask that you
recommend inexpedient to legislate on S
SP 414 thank you so much for your
time
thank you Miss
chaffy is there anybody else here that
wishes to testify that's not turned in a
paint card seeing none thank you very
much close the public hearing on Senate
Bill
414 and before we open up the next um
hearing does the committee need a 7
minute bio
break okay so um we just came back from
lunch before we started our afternoon
session so we are going to take a 10
minutes 10 hard 10 minutes um just to
recess and when we will open up the next
hearing
e
welcome back committee members we are
now opening the public hearing
for Senate Bill
415 and Senator abbis you're up again
thank you madam chair members of the
committee my name is Senator Daryl abbis
I represent District 22 serving the
communities of pelum Salem a and plastal
I'm here to introduce sener Bill 415
which will increase the penalty for
certain fentol related offenses and I
heard some members of the public
addressing this bill before the hearing
opened what when they were testifying on
the last hearing but I can tell you for
sure that if you have 5 grams of
fentanyl more they'll be a mandatory 3
and A2 years in jail if you have 28
grams or more then you will face I
believe it's seven uh years in jails a
mandatory minimum sentence uh five grams
I hear drug treatment you know rehab
mental health 5 grams of fentanyl is
approximately 2,000 to 2500 lethal doses
of fentanyl if you are an addict and you
are carrying that much of that drug
around uh one you're extreme danger to
yourself but it's unlikely that you're
just a simple addict just using drugs to
get high that is enough to kill every
elected body person in in both the house
and the Senate and the whole
building so when I when I hear that this
is you know the substance abuse this is
this is someone who's dealing drugs you
can make that you can make that leap or
presumption so that's what we're
addressing so if you have 5 grams of
fentanyl on you which or you have over
2,000 lethal doses of fentanyl on you
you're going to face a mandatory
sentence of three and a half years
because you're I believe with that
you're dealing drugs and that's that's
what it is now if you have 28 grams on
you I I'm not going to even break down
the math but clearly that person's
dealing because that person has five
times the amount as the other person
who's
so that's about 10,000 to 12,000 lethal
doses now right so that's a mandatory
sent sentence as well this person is
selling a drug Distributing throughout
the community and it's killing people I
heard someone say that the addicts and
dealers are whatever are better at
saving the lives and the First
Responders well these people wouldn't be
dying in overdosing if not for the
dealers so maybe if they're better at
Reviving them after they give them
something that almost kills them so
that's what's all right they're there so
they're already there so perhaps they're
they're doing they're able to do it I
appreciate them trying to save the
person's life but they're still
Distributing and Drug killing
people and I think we got to put a stop
to this and one way to do that if the
person is in jail they're not selling
this on the street killing people in the
state simple as that so please hope you
support the arthop pass and I'll take
any
questions do you have a question
repres I'm sorry oh Representative
no thank you madam chairman and thank
you for taking chairwoman and thank you
for taking my question um I'm wondering
about uh we we often give these
statistics about how much will kill the
average person or how much is is a
lethal dose but there's also the concept
of Tolerance not to get into a
story please don't I won't I know I know
I'm saying um but that contributed uh
the the lowering of Tolerance based on
uh someone taking Vivitrol contributed
to the death of someone I love very much
and uh so my question is when L by the
way thank you um when we talk about
these statistics on how much will
actually uh kill someone and yet someone
else talks about um people doing an
average of uh four to six grams a day
some some people that to me indicates
tolerance so how does this account for
the tolerance that someone might have
built up in uh in their use over time so
two two parts of this number one uh if
you have a cutting
agent that can
create um a higher amount so if you cut
the drug which if someone's cutting the
drug it's also fair to say that they're
a dealer now when someone overdoses it
there's a lot of things that will come
into place their overall health you know
someone with you know a poor respiratory
system is more likely to overdose at
least die from the use of uh opioids uh
the body weight would matter if they
have asthma that would matter there's a
lot of things that get factored in um
and their tolerance level so and also it
depends on how they actually take it
sometimes as well whether it's injected
or if it's you know there's a lot of
different ways to do it so there's that
this doesn't Factor it in but what I
would tell you is that the five grams of
fentanyl in you that's not been diluted
and diluted several times over is Enough
To Kill A lot of people now when I say
it's between 2,000 and 2500 lethal doses
I'm basing that on on uh what the
federal government has reported so will
vary from person to person if everyone
took the same do yes not everyone will
overdose but that's the that's the
belief that that's the approximate
lethal dose is about 2
milligrams follow um just quickly what
I'm trying to get at is that there are
uh many factors that contribute to the
potency and um the the harm that
something can do but this um but this
doesn't take that into account and and
that's okay well I think it does and to
an extent thatan when you come up with
what the number should be you know if
that was three grams or one gram I mean
one gram is still lethal doses but at
the same time 5
gr is is an when I say two 2,000 lethal
doses again I I don't I'm not sure what
someone's doing with that unless they're
selling it that's unlik that is highly
unlikely to be for one person's
individual
use representative
Newman i' just like to thank you for
taking my question I would just like to
clarify the line beginning
on line 19 where it says well it says
five five grams or more including any
adulter or or
dilutant so is it five grand of killing
level heroin or how much of it has to be
I'm not heroin how much of it has to be
Fentanyl and the rest be dilutant but it
comes up to five grams where's the
differentiation in there and thank you
for the question I'm really glad you
asked that question because I countered
that uh in a trafficking statute little
South of the Border and uh they mistake
in the legislator made in Massachusetts
is one of The Inspirations of why I ran
for office because the fentanyl
trafficking statute was not drafted
correctly which made it impossible to
convict someone of trafficking it has
since been fixed by the way but um so if
because it's a synthetic drug you have
to include the the mixing of the cutting
agent because literally a grain of salt
would change the ingredient because it's
it's an artificial drug so you really
when it comes to any drug whether it's
cocaine heroin fentanyl you have to
include any dilutant that may alter the
weight but when you're dealing with a
synthetic drug it can create something
all different altogether so you really
need to if it doesn't include that it's
really hard to prove Purity with a
synthetic drug as opposed to like
cocaine or heroin that's you know
natural drugs I would say follow up
follow up so how do how does that affect
the the statistics that you gave out
about 200 all the people in the
legislature and everything how how does
that affect those statistics or does it
well I'm basic on what the federal
government
reported so I I relied on that
information I I hope that the
information they're putting out there
about fentanyl is
accurate thank you representative Murray
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question um we heard during
testimony on the previous bill and I
think I've seen in this committee that
we are moving away from mandatory
minimums in general um in the criminal
code and um relying more on giving the
judges um you know the ability to decide
what they think is the appropriate
sentence and I'm just wondering if you
have any specific reasoning behind
wanting to bring mandatory minimums into
this part of the criminal code are you
observing judges um regularly sentencing
people to um a shorter time frame than
this or is this just something that you
think will help I'm just curious if
there's anything like behind that sure
so the War on Drugs I understand where
there's some strict mandatory sentencing
had had some uh some of the statistics
that came out suggested that that wasn't
the best approach but when we're talking
about simple possession charges that's I
understand why that's not a mandatory
sentence simple possession that is a
drug addict that is someone that needs
help I understand that there's a lot of
things that can contribute to why that
person is in that situation untreated
mental health issues or even if they
getting treated for mental health issues
they could have suffered traumatic
events there's a lot of things that
contribute to
that it's the drug dealers that are the
problem here you if there were no drug
dealers the overwhelming majority of of
this problem would be gone it wouldn't
exist anymore you would have some very
small problem here because not only are
they infecting people who are addicts
they're they're
literally they're they're in the sales
business they're seeking out new people
to sell their drug to to create new
addicts the other problem is is when
people get out of rehab or they get out
of jail they go right back in the same
circle of friends who are many are
addicts and I had a friend he was sober
for three months and he he actually
started putting on some he was you know
real frail from his drug use and when he
was getting rid of some of his old
clothes he found something in one of his
pockets that was kind of left over he
was right back to it and he's still an
act today so it's it's pretty sad how
easy it is for someone to fall back off
the ladder that quickly so the but even
though that was not a drug dealing thing
the dealers this focus on the dealer and
that's what's leading to the deaths
that's what's leading to these further
problems and you know the people who are
relapsing a big part of it is the
dealers and if you have this much
fentanyl on you I don't think it's
unreasonable to assume that you're
Distributing
it follow up thank you madam chair I
guess I'm I'm not quite referring to you
know treating dealers differently than
um those who are just possessing but
more like mandatory minimums as a tool
um like have you seen judges regularly
um you know in their discretion under
sentence in your opinion um in these
cases that you think it's necessary to
create a mandatory minimum so I I
wouldn't say I observe an individual
judge a lot of when it comes to
sentencing there's so many factors to go
into places they first offense do they
have a is the prior criminal record
sometimes it's pled down to from like a
higher charge to a lower charge so it's
really circumstantial and keep mind this
is five grams let's just say you had 27
grams so you just missed that seven-year
cut off that's a bigger deal than if you
had let's say six grams or so I think
there's a big part of it is uh a lot of
the other circumstantial things that can
go into this also it's the strength of
the case when they enter a plea that
that may play an impact there may be
some evidential issues we don't know
about so lot there's so many things that
go into sentencing uh what I will tell
you living on the border of you know
where methu and Lawrence is I Lawrence
is you know it's been titled the
fentanyl Hub of New England if they're
going to if people want to engage and
behave yourself Bo I can't control that
but in my district right along the
border uh for someone who represents
criminals they're well aware of when
they're in what jurisdiction they are
and what the penalties are and I I can
my source is very reliable
thank
you I should say
sources representative SEL thank you and
thank you for taking my question um I'm
in straford County where we've had
tremendous success from our drug courts
and so this seems to be the kind of
thing that would take diversion programs
like that away as an opportunity and I'm
just
wondering um you know in in certain
cases uh for example we hit testimony
previously that it may well be someone
who's just pulled the funds because they
had the vehicle to go pick up the stash
for their their group of friends um and
so where someone might be better suited
by going into a treatment program and
through the drug court programs I just
curious how you see this as being able
to balance with that so if let's say
there's a group of four friends one per
one of the four goes to buy a large
amount of fentanyl for the group of four
and it exceeds the five grams and how
how that would impact them at least
their eligibility for the drug court a
drug diversion program if that's the
case one is still Distributing fanol
which you know could lead to their
friends or friends death so there's that
issue but there's also some some
discretion of the prosecutor and how
they want to handle that uh but if
they're going to have over five grams
and they get caught with that amount I
mean again they they're gathering this
and they're Distributing that's my whole
point is that they're not just using
this for personal use
yes but please just ask the questions
okay
representative um you're welcome I to
clarify so you would give the discretion
to the prosecutor and not to the judge
in that
case well I'm this bill would not do
that what I'm saying is the prosecutor
could in their discretion offer to
reduce the charge as part of diversion
program that happens uh frequently
especially with someone who has um you
know a lighter record shall we say uh
someone who has kids if there's you know
they're working they're gainfully
employed sometimes it's you know if
someone's not working and they have all
this money you know it's pretty again
they can kind of put it all together
it's not rocket science but the person
has you know some other circumstance
going on that the prosec may be more
inclined to uh offer that also again
strength of evidence a lot of things
that go into it but I think I don't
think it it would it completely prohibit
them from being involved in it it just
um again but I think the example you
used sounds like they they're
Distributing fentanyl
still representative Stone thank you
madam chair thank you for Tak you my
question in your experience uh when
involving uh what we call drug dealers
in the state builds a case is it usually
uh one occurrence of a sale or is it
usually multiple sales before the actual
charges are brought with a intent to
distribute or possession with intent to
distribute
I it's kind of it's It's both I mean the
larger ones are usually the subject of a
much large you know large investigation
you know there's a kind of an Enterprise
or going on with several that's L done
with a lot of different law enforcement
agencies involved uh when it comes to
like stuff like this your lower level
dealers um that's Lui sometimes they
they can Target the person but sometimes
they can it can be as simple as either a
they know the person is been involved
and has a prior history and they kind of
can then see they're going to an area
where that's known for drug trafficking
and
engage in behavior that way sometimes
they witness hand to hands and sometimes
they don't you know when they SE a
person after they arrest them when they
observe the hand to hand the person will
have a large quantity on them uh
sometimes it's when you know drunk
driving arrest can Le these so it can be
a lot of things that kind of can invoke
this type of charge thank you in
followup in addition prior testimony you
gave was that uh certain individuals
might be inclined to become a
cooperating individual if they do have a
charge and obviously if you're in the
game then you can cooperate if you're
not in the game and it's an isolated
incident you don't have the connections
to work if that's involved does that
usually uh kind of hinder their ability
to continue with their course of
business well it depend depends on how
the cooperation agreement working what
I'm just saying is when a person's
facing a mandatory sentence or you know
a you know strong penalty that is one
tool that law enforcement does use to
get their in you know to get an
informant and that's how they go up up
the ladder so when you talk about those
larger uh drug operations to get to that
point it Lui starts lower down the
list thank
you one question I mean you're your bill
I mean we seem to be defining a drug
dealer by the amount of drugs that they
happen to be caught with on their person
isn't it more complicated than
that well it's an legal drug the person
has 2,000 to 2500 doses on them that's
can be a lethal amount if the person's
just simply an addict I mean they're
buying in bulk for how long now it seems
to me that that when someone buys in
that large quantity you can use that as
a presumption to assume that it's one
you know intent to distributed you can
use it as a presumption
to assume a lot of
things and I think in this case if you
have that large of a Quant
uh it it's it's implying that you're
beyond just a simple addict I understand
that it's not you can't I don't think
it's fair to compare that to other drugs
or you know if someone has a large
amount of marijuana like they have like
a half a pound some people buy in bulk I
guess but even then they can you can
make the assumption that the person's
dealing that illegally it's it's how
it's packaged can often lead to that
assumption as well but again when you
have that many doses I mean that's an
incredibly high amount I I mean if
there's an addict I they can explain why
they have that much on them they L don't
don't go out and buy that much because
it's also it's a money factor
too follow up yeah if
the so one of the things about mandatory
minimum laws is they don't give judges a
great deal of of discretion when it
comes to things like that so it would
seemed that just the very fact that you
had that amount of drugs that were
connected with you connected with you in
evidence is just primacia evidence of
the fact of your guilt so does anything
else come into play in in a situation
like that I mean you're a defense
attorney how would you defend somebody
if they had over five grams on them yeah
how would you do it well the search and
seizure is usually the best best way to
go about then if that's lawfully and the
test comes back as it
is you know sometimes you got to it's
what it is Johnny CER himself would uh
run into a a wall if that's the case so
no defense I didn't say there's no
defense what I'm what I'm possession
also matters where they found it so
let's say it's in the car you can defend
it other ways but if it's in their
pocket and and the search is
constitutional and it exceeds that
amount I mean there's only so much you
can do
beg for
mercy argue for Mid gain circum try to
get him into diversion program that's
that's the next step but you can't make
something on no nothing but when it
comes to this mandatory I just I guess
I'm trying to figure out if you don't
think a mandatory sentence is
appropriate what is a person doing with
that much
Fentanyl and without facing any type of
harsh or penalty do you understand that
fentanyl on this table if there was
fentanyl on this table and I touched it
I could overdose simply by just touching
it inadvertently
so that's an incredibly large amount
that no one should have on their
possession period never mind even if
you're just an addict that is ill
advised on every level thank
you follow thank you madam chair I'm
going to follow up to representative
Muse uh if you're in a situation that
you just described and you're the
defense Council that's where you would
hope to try to negotiate with the
prosecutor for plea deal which would
take the mandatory sentencing off off
the table at that level correct I I
would certainly try especially knowing
the you know knowing I'm an uphill
battle I mean again sometimes you file
that motion and before it's ruled on
that's Sometimes the best way to you
know work things out um there's a
there's again there's so many things
that go into that and again you know the
person's background you know the prior
history again they may have had six
grams or 52 grams but if they had 27 gr
you know it's it's more even though it's
the same offense it still agreed just
that would that's what you would have to
do I mean you reach a point where
there's only so much you can do on a
possession case and just to follow up
the prosecuting attorney would have some
discretion on offering a plea deal yes
thank
you thank you
Senator thank you madam
chair miss
chaffy you sorry about that again my
name is Devon chaffy and I'm the
executive director of the American civil
liberties Union and I am here to testify
an opposition to SB uh 415 which creates
mandatory minimums for certain fentanyl
related offenses um and I want to take
this opportunity here um to really dig
in a little bit further into why New
Hampshire law has is generally does not
include mandatory minimums especially
for drug related cases um here in New
Hampshire and as I I stated earlier this
is because they are expensive they are a
one-size fits-all approach to justice
that fail to take into account the
particulars of a given case
they transfer judicial discretion away
from the Judiciary to
prosecutors and perhaps most importantly
they don't work we have been down this
road previously we know that they don't
work the data is
in um I want to uh start by um just
elaborating a little bit more on the
tremendous cost that mandatory minimums
put on taxpayers and would begin to put
on the taxpayers of New Hampshire if New
Hampshire were to go down Road of
leaning towards mandatory minimums and
in doing so I want to quote Grover
norquist which is interesting for a
representative of the ACLU to be quoting
um for those of you um who may be young
and and do not know he was a longtime
tax reduction Advocate and a founder of
Americans for tax reform and Grover
norquist has stated that the biggest
problem from the P perspective of the
taxpayer is that mandatory minimum
sentencing policies have proven
prohibitively expenses he went on to
cite the skyrocketing cost of
incarceration to American taxpayers
saying that this explosion and cost is
driven by the expanded use of prison
sentences for drug crimes and longer
sentences required by mandatory
minimums and he stated that it appears
that mandatory minimums have become a
sort of poor man's
prohibition a grossly simplistic
ineffectual government response to a
problem that has been around longer than
our government itself and viewed through
the skeptical eye that I train on all
other government programs I have
concluded that mandatory minimum
sentencing policies are not worth the
high tax to Americans
taxpayers and so I would just put put to
you that you know we we have been down
this road before we know that mandatory
minimums do not work and they are not
they come at a very high cost to the
state and to the New Hampshire
taxpayers as has been discussed they
also take discretion away from judges
and they give it to prosecutors now this
has been described at how this happens
by um some of the defense attorneys
behind me but I want to also put forward
that this issue of taking power away
from the judicial branch and giving it
to the executive branch through
mandatory minimums actually has
constitutional concerns as well
separation of powers concerns and here
I'd like to quotee David Kean who's a
prominent gun rights Advocate and was an
adviser to the George HW Bush
Administration and David Keane stated
that my opposition to mandatory minimums
is rooted in conservative principles
namely reverence for the Constitution
and contempt for government action that
ignores the differences among
individuals James Madison for one
believed that a clear separation of
powers was more vital to protecting
freedom than the Bill of Rights
yet mandatory minimums undermine this
important protector of Liberty the
attempt by legislators to address
proceed problems in the justice system
by transferring power from judges to
prosecutors and the executive B Branch
violate these principles and have in the
process given prosecutors unreviewable
authority to influence sentencing
through their charging decisions and
plea bargaining
power addition Al I want to flag that
mandatory
minimums do not work we have seen them
we have seen them in in in play
previously whether it be in this state
and across the C the country and we know
that aside from anecdotal accounts there
is no statistical evidence and I will
note none that was cited by the sponsor
or the the the senator who introduced
this bill no evidence despite Decades of
experience with mandatory minimums that
they that they um have any significant
relationship to reducing crime or
reducing drug use and in fact in a 50
state study found that there was no
relationship between drug
sentencing and three drug epidemic
indicators elicit drug use drug arrests
and overdose rates so we do not see
mandatory minimums having any impact
whatsoever on crime rates drug drug use
um or or um or
overdoses moreover mandatory minimums
may actually increase the likelihood of
recidivism because harsh mandatory
minimum penalties serve to increase the
length of time in prison and Studies
have noted that there is a relationship
between longer stays and recidivism and
for these reasons I respectfully request
that the committee um uh recommends HB
415 uh in expedient to legislate thank
you thank you very
much representative
Pratt in response to that I have a
question do you think somebody sitting
in jail for 10 years can kill somebody
by giving them a drug dose I'm sorry sir
I I I'm not sure I understand question
so if somebody is sitting in jail for 10
years from a mandatory sentence do you
believe they can kill somebody by giving
them more drugs what I have seen what I
do know and what I have seen through the
data and the analysis that has have been
done is that there is no demonstrated
data that mandatory minimums actually
reduce drug overdoses and that's just
that's the evidence that we have seen
and that is why States like New
Hampshire have shifted away from
mandatory minimums as a way to address
the drug crisis in our state so that
doesn't answer my question so the person
that's sitting in jail can they now sell
another lethal dose to another kid I
don't believe so unless they have access
to those unless they have access within
our facilities thank you thank
you let's just not argue with our people
that are testifying please I I I know
but let's be very careful we're going
down a slippery slope thank you
representative are there any other
questions we're all set thank you very
much
Burns good afternoon again and thank you
for allowing me the to speak I want to
reiterate all of the points and I and in
the interest of time I I'm not going to
sit up here and repeat all of them as
pretty much all of my points that I made
about SP 414 are the same for S
sp415 but I do want to look at the
dehumanization of of the people that we
work with and that the people this
targets because with all due respect to
the senator that presented um the
sponsorship on this legislation he stood
up here and referred to people who use
drugs and people in recovery as addicts
which is a very stigmatizing term um and
this is the strategy that's often used
by law enforcement and drug policy is to
dehumanize people demonize them label
them um my daughter is not you know he
used the term simple addict versus
people who have five grams and I work
with these people every day and there
are a lot more than that um and it is
not unusual to see people with those
quantities and I think you know talking
about .1 you know 1 milligram being a
deadly dose the reality is you know when
we look at street level front lines um
some of his testimony was out of touch
with what I see so on average to give
some education on that what we usually
see are what we call 20 bags 40 bags
occasionally people buy it by the gram
um or higher level as a as a finger
what's called a finger on the streets
which is 7 to 10 gr um depending on
where you're at um the street value of
five GS generally runs $400 to $500 so
we're not talking about massive
quantities here and it's not hard for
somebody with four or five friends using
drugs to grab that to to pull together
that much money um and face a three and
a half year mandatory minimum as a
result now with this
legislation um and again kind of what I
said before with the licenses but I also
want to remind this committee that when
talking about these people these are our
kids these are our friends like not
everybody contrary to what the media
portrays these aren't all under bridges
these are people who are in our
workforces these are people who are
functioning often times that are that
are in that are being prosecuted around
this um and and often we've we've heard
the stories numerous times these are
people who may have had an injury and
were prescribed opioids and and this led
to this like we we know how this
epidemic started and it and it and it
impacts people that look just like us in
this room all across the state and those
are the individuals that are going to be
targeted with this law and those are the
people that are going to be locked up
for three and a half years without you
know and I think when we look at the
balance of power with judicial
discretion too I think often these laws
are misdirected and end up coming after
the people that we don't intend them to
so the big fish so to speak go in front
of a you get arrested and they tend to
be talked into flipping on a couple of
their of their smaller fish and those
smaller fish are the ones that end up
facing a mandatory minimum of three
years while the the larger fish that we
had hoped to Target with these laws run
off as a criminal you know they'll be a
they might be a CI for a period of time
um face less consequences well the
people that have less resources
to to get the representation they need
are targeted in this so often times you
know as I say if somebody's involved
with a cartel that we're trying to
Target here chances are they're not
touching the drugs and they're not in
New Hampshire cuz it's it's those make
fish they don't come into contact when
when we're looking at street level
dealing and most of the most of these
most of the people that I see that are
dealing in quantities of this nature are
people just like us who have struggled
with the substance disorder and are
actively using and they're sharing it
with their friends so I just want to
reiterate those points and realize that
what we're talking about here are not
grizzled criminal cartel members these
are these are people in our community um
these are my people like my daughter
people like the people I work with every
single day in Rochester do and Hampton
um those are the ones who are going to
be locked up in a prison cell for three
and a half years without the opportunity
to go to treatment Court without the
opportunity to receive diversion without
the opportunity to have any sort of
support for a substance use disorder
which should be looked at as a
healthcare issue not a criminal justice
issue I don't know when we walked away
from the we can't arrest our way out of
this notion um but it's really
unfortunate to see the pendulum swinging
this way and you know and again and
representative proud if I could just
respond to yes absolutely if somebody's
locked up for 10 years in a prison they
can they will they are still going to
have the opportunity to sell drugs
because there's an entire Underground
Market in every prison and every jail
that I've ever seen in in all of my work
and we have a Statewide criminal justice
program so unfortunately you know drugs
get into prisons too and so we're not
keeping any sort of uh trafficking
outside of prisons and I'm sure most of
the correctional Department would attest
to the fact that they struggle with this
that's why we have overdoses in prisons
and that's why they're getting the
lockone for the prisons so thank
you thank you Mr Burns do we have any
questions thank you very much
Mr
Summers good afternoon again thank you
very much for the opportunity to testify
Vice chairperson rhs and honorable
members of the committee I think um in
listening to the testimony today we can
all agree that um we want to rid our
state of dealers
and suppliers the big fish so to speak
in the in the uh opioid supply chain I
want to um though make a couple points
one when I reviewed the uh bill as it's
written I noted what I consider to be an
inconsistency in section one under the
controlled act penalties it cites 5
ounces or more of a mixture or substance
containing any of the following
including adulterants or dilutant a
cocoa leaf accept cocoa leaves and
extracts of cocoa leaves from which
cocaine echine and derivatives of echine
or other salts have been removed or B
cocaine other than crack cocaine it
salts Optical and geometric isomers and
salt of isomers C echinus derivatives or
salts isomers and salts of isomers and
it goes on to spell out this the amount
or the threshold amount for L surgic
acid diamide which is LSD and PCP and
then it talks about heroin or it
describes heroin it's analog crack
cocaine with crack cocaine which for the
record is a mistake crack cocaine
obviously is not an not an analog of
crack cocaine of of U fentanyl excuse me
but I wanted to call to to call to the
attention that in my experience in the
subus treatment uh world for the past
two decades I've never known anyone who
consumes 5 ounces of cocaine and
survives I I know a lot of cocaine
addicts but that is an extreme amount
that would suggest it comes from a
direct dealer I would ask you compare
that to the amount of fentanyl that's
cited here which is 5 G and I understand
the testimony that 5 G might might be as
much as 200 to 250 lethal doses but the
scientific me the scientific L
literature is replete with how quickly
an individual becomes addicted and
dependent physically on opioids it
occurs for some people in a matter of
days but for everyone else in a matter
of two or 3 weeks they escalate the dose
the people using five Gs are not dealers
these are people like you and me people
who might have been prescribed per
cassette or deloted for a pain problem
from their PCP and then went on to
somehow access illegal
opioids so I ask you to consider that
there's a bifurcation in this law that
we're looking one at quantities and then
we're looking at penalties and I would
suggest to this committee to please
please if we're going to keep this
legislation to at the very least
increase the amount in fentanyl of it
and its analoges to at least what uh is
cited in cocaine which is 5 ounces 5
ounces is um
120 uh grams and for the record on my
earlier testimony I talked uh to um
representative Pratt earlier the
statistic I CED was 32.3 deaths per
100,000 in New Hampshire when I was
describing overdose deaths and I'll also
state that any overdose death is too
many but I would ask that we look at the
amount here because if we keep it at
five grams we're going to incarcerate a
whole lot of citizens who are like you
and me who shouldn't be in jail who are
going to cost us in excess of hundreds
of that millions of dollars in prison
and jail jail cost and I think it's also
important as
John Burns described earlier to remember
the human in this equation this is not
the stereotypical quote junkie unquote
on the side of the street living
homeless these are people like you and
me who are going to suffer the
consequences they already are suffering
the consequences there's no one that
I've come across in my 20-year career in
the submis used addiction treatment
field when I've asked him this question
hey did you want to grow up to become an
alcohol or addict that that's responded
affirmatively when someone isn't an
addict bition goes out the window it's
no there's no longer a choice to use the
substance and I think that point really
needs to resonate with this committee
people who are actively using no longer
have a choice there is Treatment
available there are modalities including
harm reduction peer support services
medication assisted treatment but the
choice goes out the window so instead of
putting people who otherwise have led
Sterling lives but have off have an
intractable subtit disorder in jail
please consider the consequences at
least with the amount cited for Fentanyl
and its analoges and again I would
respectfully request that the the
committee opposed mandatory sentencing
minimums which we know from the data has
done nothing to keep our community safer
thank
you Mr are you okay to take a question
from the committee representative
Newman based on your comment about how
the the um the amount should be in
increased um do you have any comment
about the uh including any adulterant in
delut since it seems like we can't tell
very well what the quantity of actual
fanol is in
there that's a that's a very pertinent
question I think um it's
as far as we're concerned at the street
level what what's being sold for
fentanyl is believed to be fentanyl so
the entire substance including
adulterant is 120 grams I would be okay
with that in the
legislation thank
you thank you very
much Dr
Hannon
good afternoon members of the committee
uh my name is Joe Hannon and I stand in
opposition to SB 415 uh I'm not going to
repeat uh all the things that I've heard
that I I absolutely agree with uh I
think it's an egregious dangerous uh
thing but there were a couple little
points that I I thought of as other
people were speaking that I I thought
I'd draw your attention to um you you
know the the idea that just because
someone has an amount that is a lethal
amount or more than the average user
amount I mean we only look at that in
terms of drugs you can buy a truckload
of alcohol at the state liquor stores
you can buy U 20 cartons of cigarettes
it's totally legal these are very
dangerous amounts to have but people
don't do that just um because they're
dealing I during covid I mean I'm sure
I'm not alone people out here ran out
and bought toilet paper I still have
some left because I'm not a toilet paper
dealer I bought what I thought would be
enough to get me through the crisis now
people that are homeless or people that
are not homeless who have a job who are
working and using elicit substances they
may buy larger quantities to get through
longer periods of time I have to drive
30 minutes to get to the dentist and 25
minutes to get a haircut in this state
you know so and I have a car you know
what if someone doesn't it's very
difficult if you're living in a in a
camp somewhere or in a shelter it's very
difficult for people to go to do that on
a regular basis and the idea that even
touching it is is lethal and dangerous
it is a myth it has been debunked
numerous times by medical professionals
um and it is completely false even if
you use a fentanyl patch which is the
designed method of transporting it
through the skin transdermally if I put
a Fenty patch put 10 of them on my arm
and sat here for 5 10 minutes I probably
wouldn't even get that much of an effect
from it after a few minutes you have to
leave it on for hours even with many
hour several hours to get the effect
it's a slow release thing uh if you put
it on your skin it doesn't go through
your skin period it does not happen so
every time you've seen an incident or of
a police officer who is you know they
touched their hand and they fell down
they've never found Fen on their systems
when they've drug tested them or check
them in in for anything else it's
usually a fainting reaction or someone
who's been so scared the reason why I
bring this up is important is it doesn't
pertain directly to the bill but I think
it goes to the the stigmatizing effect
that legislation like this has and the
conversations that go on around drug use
when someone is scared of even touching
fentanyl for fear of death the chance of
someone surviving a drug overdose
because someone is scared they may touch
fentanyl if they go near that person or
do mouth to mouth or even touch their
skin they're afraid to to do that if
they're afraid the longer it takes to uh
the longer you wait to reverse an
overdose the more dangerous and and
lethal that becomes so we don't want
people to be afraid I'm not saying you
should go around and just smear it all
over your body it's probably not you
know financially advisable at least but
I think that it's dangerous to have
these talks that uh it's so bad that we
have to take the these people and they
have to mandatorily do the sentence
regardless of the circumstances uh
there's very few things we do this with
if we do this we'll have people serving
more time than if they committed
manslaughter or U vehicular homicide in
some places this is not something that
we want to go down that road it's a
sledgehammer for prosecutors this is my
last Point uh we're taking that power
like you've heard away from the judicial
branch and giving to the Executive
Branch the prosecutors can now use this
to coers people to take a deal and we
know that most people don't even go to
trial most people that get uh prosecuted
or take a plea deal if everyone that
took a plea deal everyone that got
prosecuted took a plea deal did not take
a plea deal and decided on a jury trial
our system would shut down because we
don't have the resources for everyone to
go to trial but um when someone takes a
plea deal they may not even be guilty in
some instances they're just afraid of
have oh I could you know I could do 40
you know 90 days or six months for what
I might have done but now they're
throwing this potential mandatory
minimum charge and I'm going to have to
go to jail for mandatory sentence and
they just take a plea now they some may
say that's in the interest of justice
but you know we're we're taking someone
who may have been able to get out on
something easier and had a better life
also the longer someone's incarcerated
uh you know incarceration is Creo
criminogenic if I'm saying that
correctly the longer someone's in jail
the more likely they are to to live a
life of crime you know people that are
in for 10 20 years they don't just get
out and start teaching school and Sunday
school you know Sunday school and doing
community service all the time that's
not the norm it happens but it's not the
norm um and the last part of that when
the prosecutors coer people into taking
plea Deals they often times coers and
this is the main uh rationale I've heard
from law enforcement I've spoken to is
well we want to get the next person up
the ladder so we can use this as a plea
or a tool to coerce uh either plea
bargain or to get someone higher up the
chain and that's not always what happens
but I can tell you firsthand experience
not not firsthand secondhand experience
sorry um you know I when I was a State
Rep I had uh more than one person uh
come to me and say they were a uh forced
to be a criminal informant otherwise
they had to do these seven you know 15E
sentences and they were scared to death
I had a someone who worked for me who's
had a friend who was in this position
and they were scared to death because
they were not just asked to you know U
tell on you know to to to tell on their
Partners or the person they bought the
drugs they wanted someone really high at
the chain and they kept using this
person and using them now you're putting
someone in a very dangerous position you
know we want to get the big fish
apparently I guess no one's uh saying
that's not a good idea but we're putting
people in danger by doing that and this
is a tool that can make that more of a
bludgeon for a prosecutor or law
enforcement to use to go after people
who are maybe low-level offenders who
are really just harming themselves but
now we're putting their lives in
Jeopardy by making them uh testify
against someone who may be more
dangerous and lethal and and also drug
dealers like if you lock them all up
they'll be more you know we don't have a
shortage of dealers it's actually every
time one gets arrested all you're doing
is creating a job opportunity for the
next person to move into that area so so
um you know crime's going to go up it
did in Florida after Florida crime went
up almost 50% in Florida after they
instituted mandatory minimums way back
so there's no data to support this and
there's plenty of data to show that this
is a bad idea so I ask you to please
vote this inexpedient to
legislate we're good apparently we're
not good representative Newman yeah I
just have a question about distribute is
my definition of that is just pass
around and it's not more complicated
than that I'm what you might say to that
I mean distribution I mean there's you
you're well aware of this being you know
it's um there's difference between
actually selling it an intent to
distribute um there there was laws on
the books that say if it's over this
amount then we have an intent to
distribute you know um charge but there
are people who buy for other people and
buy for groups of people you know anyone
in here who's ever you know shown up to
a party with a bottle of liquor you know
if you drank the whole thing you'd
probably be sick might have to get your
stomach pumped that doesn't make you a
dealer you know are you giving it out
you know I have a friend who has a
daughter who is in jail still to this
day because she uh bought U substance
and it was I believe it was fentanyl or
something related heroin back then and
uh she was using it with her boyfriend
they both overdosed and he happened to
die she bought it and was just sharing
it with the person that gave her you
know whatever amount the money was few
bucks and because she survived and
bought it she got charged with the you
know death resulting and she had a long
sentence and she was a victim in a sense
you know if he bought it it didn't
matter who bought it they both pulled
their money if you give me 20 bucks and
you know I take my $20 and I buy
something I give it to you is it my
fault that something happened to you
it's only a matter of circumstance that
I happen to be the one who went and got
it and if that's what we're trying to
you know prevent we're not stopping the
big level dealers most people that are
selling on the street in New Hampshire
are are users themselves uh that are
supporting their habit best they can I
mean I did it I did it in college I was
poor and I wanted Chinese food so I
ordered a you know a combination platter
every Thursday and ordered 10 egg rolls
and I'd sell the egg rolls on my floor
in the dorm paid for my meal and people
with the two drugs do very similar
things it's not unheard
of thank you
sure guess we're all having Chinese for
dinner tonight I am hungry sorry I
brought that up this late in the day no
no more thank you all right I don't have
any egg rolls but I have toilet paper
for anyone to talk to me
after is there anybody here that would
like to testify on Senate bill 415 that
is not turned in a card seeing none we
will close the public hearing for Senate
Bill 415
and one more people stay with me um we
will open the the public hearing for
Senate Bill
36 and I
believe
yeah
Senator abbis will introduce his
legislation for us or somebody's
legislation I'm not really sure
who's yep that's
his did you you just missed us you you
know that that's really what this
is good afternoon
everyone Senator Daryl abis I represent
District 22 serving the communities pum
Salem a and
plastow
and uh I am here to introduce Senate
Bill 316 which by the way I don't want
to take too much credit for this
bill so I I know a very wise man
actually wrote this
bill the chair of this
committee he wrote it last term and it
didn't actually make it out of the house
so I'm hoping some better luck this year
um the chair is not here today but um
this is has to do with possession of
intent to distribute fentanyl class
drugs
with the intent to distribute when you
import it into the state of New
Hampshire
and speaking in general terms about
fentanyl I I hear I hear a lot about
people's perception of what's going on
out there
I I guess for someone who's worked with
criminals on the ground level some want
to get better some are trying some are
not and the person that buys drugs and
then sells to their friend friends to
you know support their habit they're
making other people addicts they're
contributing to the problem do they have
a
disease sure but they're doing anything
to help themselves no and they're making
it worse for other people around them
and that they contributing to that
problem they're funding the market all
that well this fentanyl is not made in
New Hampshire it's not being made here
it's being brought here people are
bringing in here so every person that's
dying from a fentanyl over overdose in
this state it's being brought into this
state so if you're going to bring it
into the state with the intent to
distribute which can be established
several ways it's not just the quantity
amount it's how it's packaged if you
have a scales on you if you have you
know a list of your customers which
wouldn't be a very smart thing to write
down literally write down your criminal
Enterprise on paper but trust me it
happens um if you have large quantities
of of cash you know $5 $700 but you
don't have any proof of employment these
are ways they establish and tend to
distribute if you have you can sometimes
have a smaller amount but if it's
packaged in let's say 30 different 30
different bags that's one way to factor
that in as well so this is to deter
people from bringing into the state
because where I live Salem I am right
next to the fentanyl Hub of New England
and the fentanyl I mean they literally
call the route from um from Lawrence up
when if you go through L into up come
into Mar heroin Highway that's literally
the name the nickname amongst uh the
criminal Enterprises that's what they
call it what often was happening and and
credit to the Rockham County Sheriff's
Department doing a good job with this
but for a while drugs are coming from
havil and they would say hey it's cut
through New Hampshire we won't be
detected if we want to get to Lawrence
LOL well you know law enforcement to
their credit is caught on to that but
that's what's happening that's is what
we're dealing with here they're bringing
in into the state people are dying from
it and if you're going to do that we're
going to again adding it all on and I
hear a lot of Sympathy for the drug
addicts no and I think a part of the
problem is you got to hold people
accountable for their behavior there is
resources out there to deal with
substance abuse there's several
resources all right untreated if but if
you're going to be Distributing drugs to
other people no sympathy for that that's
why people are dying and if you import
them into the state you're contributing
to the problem and you're certainly not
doing anything to help help yourself so
we're having a strict penalty guess what
criminals do know when they cross over a
border into a different jurisdiction
that the penalties are different heck we
all do that with our Firearms we know if
we go to other states what we're going
to deal
with so I think we we can hold people
accountable for what they're doing and
there needs to be accountability without
accountability for this we're not going
to get through this um this opioid
crisis anytime soon so I'll take any
questions but please support out the
pass Representative no I wasn't I wasn't
laughing at you please don't think that
I was laugh with me um thank you madam
chairman and uh thank you for taking my
question it's a little bit of a repeat
it just uh it Rhymes um it's you
I mean it it's in so many different
things and what this says is any person
who enters the state while possessing
any quantity of a fenal class drug I
mean that is I mean it could be so many
different things I just I wonder is is
that what you meant like
anything so listen possession with
intent I I know the last testimony from
the last bill someone said you have to
have a certain amount to have POS uh
possession with intent uh yeah I don't
don't like to yell from the audience but
that was an incorrect statement of law
the ACT there is no quantity um amount
that would invoke the intent to
distribute it's just one of many factors
and that's the existing law already with
possession with intent so this has to do
with when you also import the fentanyl
class drug into the state because we
know that they're not making fentanyl in
the state so could you have less than
four grams or less than three grams yes
but it if you have let's say $2,000 in
cash on you you have a scales on you
these are these are if it's package in a
bunch of different small bags so if
you're you're you know your 3,000 lethal
doses of fentanyl that some people
believe apparently just for an addict's
individual use well if it's individually
bagged into single doses that's usually
another sign of
distribution uh that's wellknown I mean
expert Witnesses have testified to that
in court uh as proving possession with
intent so the actual quantity of the
drug is just one factor obviously having
a lower dose makes it much harder to
prove but when it says any dose that's
the existing Law And that's pretty
consistent throughout other other states
as
well quick followup so what what I'm
thinking about is okay so if you if you
were coming in all of those other
factors were intact right you had things
bagged a portioned you know however you
had had uh a large quantity of cash or
um whatever things I could think of
other reasons for it's a large
quantities of cash without proof of
employment it's Lu that they give away
okay um thank you and but but I guess
what my question is is is it could be in
something that you think is something
else but then when the te Police test it
it would you could see that there was
feny in it so that any quantity of feny
in something that you may have had no
idea had fenel in it in the first place
so there may not be a m minimum of 5
years for you bringing something else in
but come to find out it's got feny in it
which most things do and then it's a
mandatory minimum and you had no idea
that was in there so claiming ignorance
because what you thought was heroin
turned out to be fentanyl or your
cocaine was laced with
fentanyl I guess if that's going to be
the defense it's still possession with
intent so they're still going to face a
pretty tough
charge uh I I guess my point is we're
trying to I've been hearing a lot of
excuses for people who
are in possession of a large amount of
drugs and now importing them and doing
all the stuff and I not hearing anything
about how to hold people accountable
I've been listening to it all the whole
time and I'm just pointing it out I
understand is the treatment side I
understand that people if someone buys
you know $100 worth of a drug and they
go from Lawrence into New Hampshire I
understand that maybe you think may
think it's a harsh penalty but again
they're bringing this lethal drug into
the state it's unlikely that that's
going to be possessed with intent unless
they have the money the scale there has
to be much more to it because the high
burden of proof very difficult to prove
if they just have a few bags of
something uh if it's when they have
drugs for Beyond individual use Le you
can imply that on the amount that they
have so I've seen it happen several
times and I've had people charged with
these offenses it's
difficult to prove the possession with
intent even when they do have the
individual bags and the money thank
you representative
Muse so as as I read our current statute
it looks like um you can be prosecuted
uh simply for
transporting um fentanyl uh within the
state regardless of whether or not
you're transporting it uh across state
lines so and and I also understand just
reading our current statute um that you
can be sentenced uh for up to 30 years
for doing that so what I'm not
understanding is
is how we're making people any more
accountable uh by passing this bill than
they already are under our current
law I can answer that for you different
context I had a Someone who lived in
Worcester County came all the way to
essic County to just rob a few cars and
trying to understand my knowledge of the
criminal underworld as I do my job why
would you drive that far away I mean you
you you came all the well they didn't
want to get ID that was their answer I
said well you getting awfully close to
New Hampshire how come you didn't come
up here and their answer was well the
penalties up there one breaking into
people's property not as ill advised in
New Hampshire based on some of the stany
ground laws also the type of penalty
they would face was much harsher that
that's coming from someone who's
breaking the law in another state so if
someone's going to be transporting
Fentanyl and engaging all his activity
we can't control what happens in other
states we can control what happens here
they know and when dealers are
transporting throughout New England uh
there there was a time when it the
advice that would go out there was to
not stop when you're traveling through
New Hampshire that was before a bail
reform because they don't they want just
keep on
going that was what that's those were
normally the orders of the people who
are trafficking drugs throughout the
area so people are if you're going to
import drugs into this state that's what
we're trying to deter that message will
be known in the criminal trust me they
will
know they and I'm I'm telling you that
that will be act as a
deterrent Massachusetts right now if you
have a large capacity firearm that's
that has a magazine azine full it's
without a license it's 18 months
mandatory sentence all the people don't
like mandatory sentences reach out to
that state but the fire I'm and it's in
18 months on top of that for just the
magazine I live right on the border I
know very well not to bring that firearm
into that state I travel quite
frequently they have my offices located
there because that's the law and I
respect the law when I'm in When in Rome
so we're asking people to do the same
here
senator for I if I may ask a question um
so if you could put on
your your employer hat for a second um I
don't remember the the person testified
to it but there was a comment that was
made about when the police come
everybody's running right they're taking
off which which by the way is also can
be a crime of resisting arrest so I
would whoever recommended that um very
advised well
just I've never ran from the cops but
that's not the point um so so my my
question is this if if so that comment
was made about you know generally
speaking you see the cops and you're
you're booking it and I'm the one on a
touch right why would the person be
booking it when they see the
cops not recommended they either quite
often they have a warrant out sometimes
believe it or not the the cops and
people who are involved in the drug
trade it's not always their first
interaction together they they tend to
recognize each other especially in some
communities which I mean you'll see that
in the police reports why they're
following the person in the first place
they someone so was a known trafficking
they would cite in the report but the
previous arrest they had involving drug
traffick with this
individual you know when when they're on
patrol they're you know when the drug
task force doing their thing they see it
and then when they go to stop the person
the person
runs so quite often they run and then
try to throw whatever they have on them
and by the way that does destroy any
search and seizure
argument thank
you and I just clarify it was not a
recommendation it was just an offering
that of what they observe happening that
running from the
police well it's recorded on video so we
can play it
back I'll be happy to thank you
senator
thank you please support autop pass
thank
you right Mr
curiel
my name is Dominic Cel I'm a second year
law student at UNH Franklin Pierce
School of Law I have a criminal justice
degree in um from San Diego State
University and today I'm requesting that
the committee amend SB 316 simply by
adding the word knowingly in front of
transports I think you'll find that my
experience living in Southern
California
and my legal background my legal
training has prepared me to spot out
this slight um I guess you could say
inadequacy of the bill with all due
respect for the makers of the bill but
the word knowingly appears nowhere in
the
um in the bill
and from my
experience um I had a cooworker who was
he was offered around $5,000 to
transport to drive a car basically just
from Mex just across the Mexican border
that's all he was told is you're going
to drive this car and in fact that's
what these cartels have been doing for
years they've been outfitting
cars um with hidden compartments and
I've actually included um just an
article in in my written testimony they
outfit these cars with these
compartments and they hire people on the
American side of the Border because um
it would be suspicious to hire a Mexican
national to drive into
America and the money is too good to
turn turn down it's it's an incredible
amount of money for somebody who may be
struggling and it's an easy
job so I'm not here to argue over a
mandatory minimums today I think this is
a a title wave that um has momentum
I want to use my training from UNH uh
law school to protect criminal
defendants and um this would protect
criminal defendants um there's a legal
concept called men's Rea which which is
translates to mental state each criminal
um statute has a mental state if there's
none the the the court May read in a
mental
state um however I want to save the the
state time and money I don't want to see
the state U I don't want to see another
one of these cases in my textbooks I see
it all the time and this this reminded
me of a case I read um in criminal
law So to avoid unnecessary litigation
let's just add in the word knowingly
it's a it's a big change um
but um it
is it's a level of
culpability um New Hampshire recognizes
as um linked in my written
testimony um New Hampshire NH rev stat
and
626 uh colon 2 in my conclusion um
describes level of culpability in New
Hampshire and it actually alludes to um
attaching a mental state a men's Rea to
each material element of the offense and
as you know um transporting is a
material element of this
offense
um so we are in the middle of an opioid
epidemic and I can tell you firsthand
that um the reason we've we've gotten to
this place is is fentol and the reason
that cartels are are producing it at an
extraordinary rate is it's easy to um
produce you can produce it in a house
whereas um cocaine requires
just a enormously large field of cocoa
leaves and sometimes the Mexican
Government will will um burn down these
crops
and so these cartels are getting um
experience
from Chinese chemists coming across the
border teaching them how to make these
drugs and they're making it in houses
they're called
phenias
and I just would like to to see any
criminal defendant um hired without the
knowledge of
transporting what they're transporting I
know it seems ridiculous that you
wouldn't know what you're transporting
but
um this is is sort of adding an
additional layer to the intent to
distribute so if the state was to find
scales and baggies as the former speaker
referred to that could show intent and
actually criminal history could be um
is is can be used against a criminal
defendant to show um propensity to
commit a crime so um I would like to
protect um the People
by by adding this mental men's Rea in
front of the word
transporting um thank you very much and
I'm open asking answering any questions
representative Reed thank you madam
chair first my first thought about this
men's Rea is um if somebody approached
me and said would you drive this car
across the
border um for $5,000 I think that would
trigger a red flag of course you know
it's just ridiculous to not know
something's off with that and how would
you Pro prove now um a men's Rea or no
somebody had knowledge of what they were
doing if their goto default would be I
didn't know
yeah so I don't know I think that's kind
of a stretch but if you could uh you
know elaborate a little of course thank
you very much for the question
um what a court now I'm a I'm a
second-year law student um I'm set up to
work with the district attorney this
this um summer so I don't really know
the ins and outs but I I did look up
knowingly in the New Hampshire um
statute and the criminal code and and um
it's an it's a subjective standard so
the the prosecution would just inquire
exactly what you just said what did you
at what what what did you know it's a
very subjective test so people wouldn't
just be able to say oh I didn't know
because the pro a good prosecutor will
ask question will say what questions did
you ask how did you not know this is
exactly um and to to be
clear I am um
totally I'm for putting people in jail
if they knowingly um distribute or
transport and I'm
even more
for having these
people um be accountable for asking
questions and not playing dumb and I
don't think playing dumb would by adding
this word in front of transports it
would not allow a criminal defendant to
play dumb in my in my view I think it's
a great bill I really do and and it's it
um
I I I I really do I really appreciate
this build and at first I had um well
I'll just move on
to see no more questions thank you very
much thank
you
Claire I thought you might
good afternoon commune members uh my
name is Claire bich I am also a seconde
law student um at UNH law here in
conquer I'm very passionate about
criminal law I plan to go into criminal
prosecution after graduation um so I do
appear here today to support sb316 just
with a couple
modifications um while I Court haral
penalties for the possession of fental a
minimum of 5 years is a harsh price to
pay without first setting a minimum
quantity required uh before that
sentence goes into effect so under the
current draft even Trace Amounts of
fentol will land some in prison for five
whole years and mandatory minimums
aren't new in New Hampshire um so I've
provided two examples one is RSA 6512 2B
U where there's a minimum sentence of 3
years for a subsequent or second offense
of a felonious use of a firearm um so
the second time that a felon uses a
firearm is when a minimum sentence is
used and then also RSA 318
b265 this will look a little familiar
considering this is the RSA that's being
amended in this bill um so only after a
person manufactures cells dispenses Etc
in or around a school is a mandatory
minimum imposed and in this case that
minimum is only a year and that's for
exposing School AG children to any kind
of
drug so in comparison to these examples
5 years is a steep priced pay for even a
firsttime offense for any amount in
fentol while entering the state of New
Hampshire mandatory minimums also
eliminate judicial discretion to impose
a prison term lower than the statutory
floor making specific information about
the offense or the offender irrelevant
at least to the extent that facts might
call for a below minimum
sentence historically manum mandatory
minimums have only burdened our criminal
justice system by making people serve
sentences that may not provide the
correct deterrent effect for them um so
I cited to a study sponsored by the US
Department of Justice that shows that
mandatory minimum sentences do little or
nothing to actually DET deter people
from committing crimes and that's an
expensive risk to make when in 2020 one
I believe the New Hampshire Department
of Corrections um estimated that the
annual cost to keep someone in prison is
$4,380 so in conclusion I respectfully
ask that the committee modify SB 316 to
either lower the minimum sentence
require a certain amount of fenta before
the minimum minimum sentence is actually
imposed or provide exceptions or
situations where judges can impose a
reasonable sentence thank you
thank you Miss be are there any
questions thank you very
much Mr
Lin thank you so much um again Ted St
here on behalf of the New Hampshire
Association of criminal offense lawyers
I think that everyone is here who was
here when I testified earlier um with
respect to SB
414 in opposition to it I'm not going to
repeat any of that that's why I didn't
ask to um speak with respect to the
related Bill
sp415 the only reason I came up here is
to express something that may be obvious
to everyone in the committee and if so I
apologize but I'm only going to take up
a minute or two of your times just late
in the day and it just feels so obvious
the other bills I'm just going to call
um well intention but misguided but this
this bill just seems completely
broken the people who go to
Massachusetts to get drugs to bring them
to New Hampshire are us it's not
methampetamine we can't make it
ourselves in our kitchen just as the
senator said it all comes from somewhere
else so for every drug dealer in south
of Salem and methan or or havo or
Lawrence who drives across the border to
sell there's probably five to 10 New
Hampshire residents who drive down to
those cities to buy and when they come
back now they're facing a mandatory
minimum only because a mandatory minimum
five years with no exceptions even for a
first offender simply because they chose
to buy their drugs in Lawrence instead
of Salem OR in in um in um you
know in Newburyport instead of Hampton
Beach it's crazy this doesn't make any
sense at all and I'm I'm probably being
a little intemperate in how I describe
it but that's what this bill would do
what it would the result would be if it
has any deterrent effect at all
Massachusetts drug dealers would just
set up more operations in New Hampshire
so they're so they have the stuff here
and they're selling it here so they're
unlikely to be caught transporting it
across the border this does not make any
sense all the drugs are coming from
elsewhere our own citizens who are sick
with addiction are going across the
boorder to get it we should not put them
in prison for five years for driving
that extra mile from Salem into methan
or wherever they end up and that's all I
have to
say thank you very much are there any
questions
thank you very
much uh committee members before well I
will close the public hearing um before
everybody runs out um two things if you
could just please uh join me in Wishing
Karen a happy birthday
today turn on your microphone so her
happy
birthday oh yeah I can't happy birthday
Karen I think she's still in there
listening to us happy birthday Ken and
happy birday and before you all head out
hold on just one
second with me
people
just to let you
guys I think
represent um it looks like the the
Senate has put all of our bail bills
into one giant Bill
and finance it's the house no it's the
house
finance